[Musique]
et bonjour à tous salut Laurent comment
vas-tu aujourd'hui salut Stéphane
bonjour à tous et bien écoute ça va
parce que on a toujours nos Français on
va voir des beaux matchs aujourd'hui
ouais on a été déçu hier évidemment avec
les défaites de Jules et Ali resa mais
c'est une double élimination et donc
c'est éliminer une fois ça laisse encore
une chance il n'en restera plus qu'un au
maximum ce soir de Français Stéphane
c'est ça ça marche comme ça il joue des
matchs en deux parties maintenant donc
c'est très rapide c'est un partout il y
a l'Armageddon on respirera le concept
de la main gedon mais donc deux parties
une fois blanc une fois noir et ensuite
les les deux vainqueurs des matchs de
perdants jouent ensemble et s'élimine
dans un deuxième match donc cette cette
journée qui peut durer on sait pas trop
ça dépend si les armageds donc pas mais
en tout cas voilà bon on aura au mieux
un français au pire au pire Nakamura on
imagine pas shimanov sortir tout le
monde quand même ça serait dur
on a vu les deux Français perdre donc on
a vu déjà Jules qui a joué contre
qui est très très dur à battre dans ces
formes-là et on a eu aussi
on a eu aussi qui a perdu et j'ai eu la
préparation hier le Dame des trois
c'était pas un mois au slip c'était
vraiment il a raté le matin en un coup
quoi alors il a le dame d'accord il a
pas vu le match
ok bon donc voilà malheureux allez
raisonnable qui a pas bien joué car hier
il a un petit tour parce qu'on sent
connard il est largement à sa portée on
sent qu'il y avait il y a des bouts de
parties où il joue beaucoup mieux et
voilà ça c'est jouer sur quelques gaffes
de l'inattention un peu d'énervement
aussi parce que le match probablement se
passer pas aussi facilement qu'il
espérait et donc voilà faut être là du
début jusqu'à la fin bravo à colar ce
qui a su saisir sa chance face à un
colosse comme comme Ali resa numéro
demandé Alain quand même il y a raison
on va le rappeler il a il avait il a pas
encore 20 ans donc il est clairement
installé à la deuxième place mondiale
donc bon grosse perf de de colors on va
voir aujourd'hui évidemment choque des
Titans on s'attendait peut-être aller
voir en finale quoi que c'était pas
possible au moins un demi-finale mais
peut-être peut-être en finale et il en
restera plus qu'un match de la peur
entre Ali resa firuga et Ikaru Nakamura
la star américaine on nous dit qu'il y a
un écho peut-être alors est-ce qu'on est
bien au niveau du son dites nous dans le
chat bonjour à tous sur moi je regarde
en priorité évidemment le chat de twitch
James com fr n'hésitez pas évidemment si
vous êtes j'ai vu des gens sur chassen 4
n'hésitez pas à venir nous parler sur le
chat de twitch c'est le mieux et si vous
êtes sur Youtube le pouce bleu on
s'abonne chaîne et comme ça on est
notifié et on vient vous faire un petit
coucou de temps en temps mais évidemment
le chat principal pour nous c'est le
chat de twist de twitch pardon chetcom
fr
voilà et on va voir donc ça commence
toujours avec un peu de retard avec
cette chèques de de faire play hein donc
c'est les arbitres qui regardent le
fair-play c'est à dire qu'ils regardent
un peu la pièce dans laquelle vous jouez
j'ai eu affaire à ça donc ça dure deux
trois minutes c'est fait avec
bienveillance mais bon voilà il faut que
les joueurs arrivent un peu en avance et
effectivement j'ai l'impression que les
gens sont pas très ponctuels mais tout
le monde est là on est sur le zoom et
puis j'avais c'est vrai j'avais quatre
joueurs sur les 8 seulement sur le zoom
alors je me demande si
parce qu'en fait là j'ai les seuls
joueurs que j'ai si les joueurs qui ont
perdu hier donc je me demande s'ils ont
pas fait une roue exprès pour les
perdants
dans ce cas dans ce cas c'est pas très
malin c'est à dire je peux pas suivre
les deux même temps ce qui veut dire que
si j'ai un Français qui gagne le petit
père on va devoir choisir ah non
on le voit oui
ils ont fait du propre
à France équiper on lui dit au revoir et
à la prochaine fois mais par contre
c'est vrai qu'on a des beaux matchs avec
notamment un carwana d'où ça torov et
bien qui promet
c'est quand on a pas ou ça torof non ça
offre Collard ça te refaire le gros lot
qui a pas joué qui joue pas à lire et ça
donc non pardon c'est Van forest alors
je rencontre vraiment n'importe quoi
c'est Van forest ce vainqueur
dikkaunakamura qui joue contre collars
et ouais donc ça fera un finaliste
surprise et dans l'autre demi-finale
c'est plus
disons c'est plus en attente est-ce
qu'on pouvait prévoir avec carwana
abdosa torov Abdou satorov qui a fait tu
as parlé il y a un de Jules on a su et
Jules mais nous a fait un très très gros
match notre
ami soit torov alors je lui a pas
démérité évidemment il y a toujours des
regrets sur ces matchs de rapides parce
que
évidemment c'est du rapide on prend des
décisions
souvent assez intuitive et qu'on peut
regretter encore plus qu'en partie
langues plus tard voilà on va voir Jules
qui a shimanov aujourd'hui largement à
sa portée mais attention le deuxième
match s'il y a un deuxième match il sera
il sera costaud mais je crois qu'on va
su en priorité fil rouge à la Camorra
quand même parce que là on a des on a
des champions
et attention ils peuvent faire une
remontée c'est des joueurs qui sont
capables de tout gagner jusqu'au bout
donc clairement on l'a déjà vu
d'ailleurs Nakamura il a déjà gagné le
précédent tournoi en faisant ça en
battant deux fois caroanna en battant
manuscrit en demi-finale et deux fois
car wanna en finale qui avait tout gagné
donc il a battu une fois double
élimination le même jour on prend les
mêmes on recommence et il l'a rebattu
c'était assez incroyable
alors on voit les joueurs qui attendent
parce que les joueurs enfin nous on voit
les caméras alors je peux vous mettre
aussi des caméras si vous voulez
regarder
donc on va partir sur ma caméra tu m'as
dit après on pourra quand même voir les
deux parce que j'ai installé les deux
setup ouais on va regarder les deux et
puis Jules hein peut-être van nous
rejoindre en tout cas ok ouais bah ouais
donc si on a hier on a eu lieu
contre contre on espère qu'on qu'on
l'aura encore aujourd'hui après sa
victoire contre Ali resa en deuxième
match c'est ça voilà
c'est tout le malheur qu'on lui souhaite
donc il y avait de l'écho il n'a plus un
frais apparemment
alors alors alors
ça paraît étonnant j'ai fait une bêtise
technique
le stream et nous on a un appel on a un
appel discord quoi donc nous on est
censé
que nous on a il est différent de ce que
ils ont tout le temps donc comment je
peux pas vous rendre compte en fait si
tu veux
je t'entends pas comme eux
je comprends pas là et le match qui
devrait pas tarder à commencer donc je
te confirme j'ai bien que les que les
perdants
c'est quoi je vais me
je vais vérifier en fait
quand je vais faire je vais me couper
je suis pas cost
c'est pour ça que j'arrive pas à choisir
l'arôme
c'est Simon Mac je sais pas quoi là
non mais pas du tout désolé cher ami
mais ça vient de chez toi
je fais peur non non c'est même pas de
chez toi ça vient de chez notre ami la
Rico chez take fresh flucopates
il faut que je parle
alors peut-être que c'est ses revenus je
sais pas j'ai pas l'impression
et j'entends un petit peu est-ce que toi
tu entends quelque chose chez moi non
non
peut-être baisser un peu mon son ouais
je vais baisser
saturé un petit peu
en privé à lui
alors
ces fameuses parties
est-ce qu'on a quelque chose qui a
commencé j'ai pas l'impression
on va voir Jules
de Partie 1 contre contre shimanov c'est
tout de suite
c'est tout de suite très chaud ça donne
pas le droit à l'erreur on rappelle le
système de l'Armageddon en cas de un
partout dans l'image des perdants il
joue que deux parties dans le braquet
des perdants tandis que dans le braquet
des gagnants ils en jouent 4 donc deux
parties 15 + 3 s'il y a un partout un
blanc en noir évidemment c'est un
partout c'est le moment de la vente aux
enchères des pièces noires et de la
nulle qualificative on a vu une hier
entre airesa firoga et Dimitri Collard
proposé 8,20 pour avoir les noirs et le
doigt et le droit de faire nul contre 15
minutes pour les blancs tandis que
Dimitri Collard a proposé quasiment 10
minutes un peu moins je crois 9-25
et pour avoir le droit d'avoir les noirs
et le droit à la nul qui fait en fait
gagner la partie finalement c'est à
l'IRESA qui a donné l'enchère la plus
petite avec 8 20 et donc il a eu les
Noirs mais
six minutes et 40 secondes de moins à la
pendule
il a jamais vraiment fait son retard il
a jamais complètement égalisé et ça a
été une victoire très convaincante de
Collard donc faut toujours faire
attention ce droit de faire nulle
qui a commencé alors je viens de perdre
des caméras je vous explique pourquoi
c'est parce que tout simplement j'ai
écrit au gars qui s'occupe du zoom de
mettre dans la bonne salle ce qui n'est
pas fait avant et du coup ça a été fait
et
donc maintenant et ben il faut que je
règle tout ah non c'est bon
presque et on a une Française de la part
de d'Ali Reza alors c'est là que moi
qu'elle est noire dans celle-là
parce que là les caméras sont pas bonnes
je vous change tout ça ouais j'ai donc
allez résa firoga allez noir face à
icarbonaka mort et je joue la française
bon peut-être c'est une ouverture de
toute façon tout à fait correct la
française
faut la plutôt plutôt quelque chose
voilà que Ali Alaza c'est pas son
répertoire principal c'est plutôt une
arme pour utiliser en surprise en tout
cas à très haut niveau et donc e46 c'est
4 crosses surprises de NACA alors là il
y a un choix entre évidemment dès 5 ou 5
on va prendre le centre d'une manière ou
d'une autre c'est 5 retomberait dans une
Sicilienne des 5
ça retomberait peut-être ça dépend
des cinq D4 il veut faire ou alors
prendre en D5 quand je sais pas dans
quoi ça ressemble en tout cas il a joué
C5 allez-renza et donc il joue une
défense sicilienne du coup on va voir ce
que veut Ikaru peut-être cavalier F3
certainement il y a un moment il faut il
faut faire quelque chose pour essayer de
jouer des deux des quatre et d'occuper
le centre
de
alors on a ce truc là je vais baisser du
coup le son de mon parce que moi j'ai
les couilles
ouais et cavalier FC alors ça c'est une
ligne assez assez connue en tout cas
c'est trois ici avec les blancs les
noirs jouent fou B4
et c'est censé rien donner avec les
blancs mais c'est tout à fait jouable
c'est ça reste très très solide et non
il prend ces 6 d'abord B prend ses 6
attention on peut pas faire E4 5 on
croit qu'on peut faire 4,5 mais il y a
un échec peut faire très très mal en A5
et qui gagne un pion voilà vous avez les
Noirs ici et les temps ne marche pas
c'est bien ça
les temps ne marche pas et il joue 5
lui-même alias parce que justement le
coup 5 menacé
donc c'est ça le c'est ça le concept
et voilà on va jouer sur case noire on a
un peu moins d'espace mais on va essayer
de mettre ce fou ce fouet fit soit c'est
5 soit en B4 les deux cases sont pas mal
et c'est tout à fait correct pour les
noirs
voilà les carreaux commencent à
l'habitude et c'est pas du tout de
gagner dans les ouvertures il a très
confiance en ses qualités
ensuite
je suis d'accord avec toi un petit peu
un petit peu saturé le son ça je sais
pas je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
effectivement là je peux pas
peut-être un peu fort en fait peut-être
ça le truc
un petit peu
un tout petit peu je viens de changer
est-ce que ça va un peu mieux le son
et Laurent que ouais
et Dame des trois je vais par icaru
Nakamura ok bon mets un petit coup pour
jouer dame G3 certainement c'est une
idée thématique à un investissant on
fait pression sur E5 et G7 comme tu
viens de le montrer bon ma foi comme
d'hab un peu de sang son style de combat
de rue il veut tout de suite quelque
chose de
pas étudier et intéressant très
compliqué de très compliqué dès le début
et donc bon ça le dérange
particulièrement je pense que ça en faut
dans le 3 il va ok non MG3 il va ok
on peut imaginer que en fait il y a un
point qui va être sans doute perdu
mes petits rois qui sans doute essayer
de jouer bon jeu il y a quel problème
ramener le roi pour faire une fourchette
et puis même sans faut prendre un F2 on
sent qu'il y a quand même du jeu pour
les Noirs il y a pas mal d'avance de
développement et ça peut ça peut arriver
assez vite
alors le truc c'est que à mon avis sur
dame G3 rock il veut faire fois OK
hier qu'il était arrivé en Norvège il va
jouer le norwichesse
d'ici une semaine donc c'est vrai qu'il
y a le décalage horaire je suppose que
ben voilà il s'acclimate un petit peu
c'est différent des États-Unis le voyage
est long donc voilà Hikaru très pro
comme d'habitude et puis c'est vrai que
ce tournoi peut durer 5 jours donc en
fait il est un peu obligé d'arriver en
avance parce que si parlent le 26 le
norwei commence le 29 bref ça peut
donner quelque chose de
d'assez compliqué à gérer donc il a
voyagé la veille du début du tournoi
et c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il est un
peu
on l'a pas trop reconnu hier je sais pas
ce que tu en penses mais il a été moins
c'est moins convaincant que d'habitude
ça c'est clair il a perdu quand tu
ordonnes Forrest donc bon toujours
à être vraiment
vraiment un gros rasoir et tout gagner
quoi et hier écoute il s'est fait quand
même bon il a perdu trois deux hein au
final ouais et il était très énervé
particulièrement à la fin de partie et
notamment il est parti sans abandonner
il arrache quitte ouais il arrive
parce que c'est un joueur qui bon c'est
un streamer c'est un personnage
mais je l'avais jamais vu autant énervé
je pense
que comme il était hier vraiment non
peut-être
mauvais
vraiment vraiment
je pense qu'elle va pas trop arrangé les
[Musique]
blancs
il y a beaucoup de gens qui adorent les
finales mais là elle est pas terrible
pour les blancs alors plusieurs raisons
la première de la c'est que bon moi j'ai
un seul lot de pion vous voyez que j'ai
un groupe de pions j'ai aucun pions
isolé j'ai une colonne ouverte avec ma
tour ici ben il y a plutôt deux groupes
chez les Blancs donc mental group plus
les pions sont solides ensemble et la
deuxième raison est surtout cette raison
là c'est qu'en fait à cause des pions E4
et C4 et ben non seulement le foot carte
blanche qui m'a été très mauvais parce
qu'il pourra pas il aura du mal à
s'activer à vraiment trouver un chemin
pour bien se placer parce que tout
dépend de cases donc on dit que c'est le
mauvais coup et en plus avec E4 et C4
qui s'appelle un peu le le Maroc dit
instructure maroczi pour pour blanc et
ben ça va avoir souvent pour les Noirs à
la case D4 donc si un jour j'arrive à
mettre un petit cavalier en des quatre
le cavalier pourra plus jamais être
chassé par un pion et en cas de
imaginons c'est pas tu fais un cavalier
2 tu échanges mon cavalier en de 4 et
ben je prends j'aurai un pion passé qui
sera protégé sans doute et donc voilà
donc dans tous les cas cette finale elle
est pas bonne et c'est ce qui vient de
se passer je viens de me faire
complètement
non mais il y a plus de pions il y a
aussi donc tu as parlé de la structure
de pion alors c'est plus
il y a plus de pions au centre aussi
pour les Noirs c'est ce qu'il faut voir
mais ça peut potentiellement créer un
pion passé
éloigné pour les pour les blancs aussi
avec B4 à 4 à 5 donc faut faire
attention à ça donc je pensais pas
honnêtement
je pensais pas qu'il allait changer
je pense pas que la finale soit si
mauvaise pour les blanches parce que
c'est assez équilibré
[Musique]
c'était honnête ouais non mais bien sûr
cette histoire de mauvais fou moi j'ai
beaucoup de mal avec cette histoire de
mauvais fou surtout quand on est
avantage d'espace comme c'est le cas ici
avec ce foot casse blanche alors il y a
un mauvais fou et mauvais fou tu vois
mais là il l'avantage d'espace je trouve
qu'il est alors effectivement il est sur
la case des pions et c'est vrai que si
on se retrouve en finale de fou ça sera
un désastre euh pour les blancs mais on
y est pas encore et on a quand même un
avantage d'espace donc ce fouet pas
encore si catastrophique que ça mais
effectivement j'ai pas l'impression
alors là pour abonder dans ton sens hein
à mon avis c'est très clair que les
Blancs ne jouent pas pour la vente ici
et peut-être j'ai trois F4 et poser des
questions parce que effectivement tu as
noté aussi la case des quatre pour le
cavalier mais alors on est loin c'est ça
le problème d'y arriver en plus donc je
peux pas mais sur le long terme en fait
c'est un avant-poste que je peux
largement avoir ici et puis c'est vrai
que ça m'a structure bon j'ai un pion
ici qui va être un pion arrière sur la
colonne D mais que je pourrais assez
facilement défendre les blancs a priori
vont être deux fois dessus je peux pas
mettre de cavaliers ou de fou sur ton
assise donc c'est très facile à défendre
et ensuite il va falloir essayer de m'en
œuvrer un peu voir ce qui se passe mais
voilà comme tu l'as dit aussi sur dans
une telle de roi
et ben les blancs seraient peut-être
gagnant avec ton idée on va s'éloigner
de se procurer hier enfin un pion passé
éloigné ici donc le principe du plan
s'éloigner c'est pour ça qui va forcer
le roi adverse à venir chercher le pion
et quand je viendrai changer le pion et
ben je pourrais gagner du temps pour
aller manger des pions qui sont plus
vers le centre à l'intérieur de
l'échiquier donc ça c'est des trucs
c'est des thèmes ok on pense pas
aussitôt mais c'est vrai que c'est plein
de choses à prendre en compte donc
avoir tout à fait bon début très mourant
de la part de
franchement c'est pas très
impressionnant il veut faire je sais pas
ce qu'il veut faire peut-être ou droit
B2 améliorer ses pièces mais ça paraît
alors n'accueil il faut voir aussi que
souvent il est content une petite nul il
a les Noirs il a confiance dans sa
technique défensive il est content s'il
arrive en Armageddon donc il est souvent
pas très ambitieux comme ça il attend
ses chances il va pas se
pas prendre des risques inconsidérés
est-ce qu'on y aurait pas voir allez on
peut aller voir à midi
et ben écoute intéressant les cinq parce
que alors bon je vais essayer de
comprendre à mon humble niveau
une idée des blancs c'était j'ai trois
F4 déjà
et j'ai 5 on peut dire que sur G3 tu
veux faire G4
ou même ouais ou H5 H5 et sur H4 G4 H5
vache 4 tu vois un peu pénible
à mon avantage et tu fais H4 je fais G4
et tu n'as plus jamais le jeu
F4 toujours la première passion et ce
pion qui sera arriéré en G3 et en fait
c'est un coup assez profilactique j'ai
cinq qui a l'air assez bizarre mais en
fait qui est alors hyper intéressant ça
craint trop un F5 c'est ça le problème
mais en fait c'est pas trop utilisable
qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire qui a été
trois peut-être mais bon
ok encore une fois voilà c'est un qui
joue à les raisins il aime pas
ça se voit et attendre donc il veut
créer du jeu alors évidemment c'est à
double tranchant peut-être aussi que
Nakai connaît son client il a joué cette
finale aussi c'est un peu à anti-ali
raisin parce que évidemment aime bien le
jeu dynamique donc il comprend très bien
que la finale est pas avantageuse pour
lui mais il peut c'est ce que nous a dit
Julie c'était un peu son plan de match
qu'il a pas réussi à mettre en œuvre
après il faut le réussir à mettre en
œuvre mais de jouer des finales et je
pense qu'à certains joueurs comme Naka
qui sont très forts sur la psychologie
et sur le style des adversaires qui
clairement
va se disent aujourd'hui je vais jouer
plus MOOC d'habitude c'est une petite
finale même si elle égale j'ajoute et
voilà ça rend certainement dans son dans
son plan de jeu
alors tu vas aller voir du coup
il y a une vente d'avance de la
française encore une française très très
intéressante chez notre ami Jules il a
joué une vente d'avance
qu'elle est blanc ici il y a des blancs
on va se mettre partout au début
depuis le début ça donne ça
française
la fameuse ligne cavalier
c'est intéressant tout ça alors
évidemment il y a énormément d'options
c'est quelque chose qui est très riche
stratégiquement très dur à jouer pour et
de couleur regardez tous les deux pour
faire [__] des trois pour ce fou tape
sur H7 on peut lancer une attaque avec
damage 5 peut-être qu'avec 3 qui peut
arriver
donc ça paraît ça paraît très logique de
remettre ce fou sur cette diagonale mais
position très très complexe évidemment
shimanov qui joue
assez vite sans trop il a un style un
très bon technicien shimanov
alors évidemment ça a des défauts
parfois un peu mécanique
mais style un peu mécanique mais bon
voilà il a fait tomber 8 B5 B4 une
petite attaque de minorité voilà il pose
des questions clairement pas trop
d'ailleurs comment on joue ici avec les
Blancs certainement C4 je sais pas
installer un cavalier en E4 ou un C4
mais une position pas mal parce qu'en
plus là il peut s'exprimer pas mal
techniquement sur le roi sur le Renoir
[Musique]
très rapidement
et maintenant je sais pas trop ce qu'il
veut faire c'est 4 alors c'est connecté
avec quoi c'est quoi l'idée
et si le C4 maintenant
c'est 4 étoiles
pour avoir une option exactement donc ça
a l'air 4 ou un C4
en fait peut-être tourcer un pour
reprendre de la tour en C3 et avoir
cette cette colonne ouverte si elle
s'ouvre en C direct on prend ses trois
tours français 3 alors évidemment ça
fait un pion passé protégé pour les
Noirs mais parfois on peut tourner
autour
et ça peut être intéressant je suis pas
sûr et la tourbe coulisser ensuite un
tour c'est un pion prend ses trois tours
penser 3 et non il fait ses 4 ok alors
moi ça m'avait l'air alors bon
maintenant de faire ces quatre
maintenant pour en fait en cas de prise
ou de mouvement du pionnier avoir le
Caval qui vient là et après pendant
qu'elle va les mettre mais c'est quoi la
différence entre cavalier B3 plus C4 la
nuance
si on arrive je parce que non mais j'ai
calculé rapidement peut-être ces quatre
fous des quatre attaque de pions
prendre S5 tu fais ou prendre des 5 et
je fais cavalier F3 ça me semblait très
fort un moyen de protéger 5 de
t'attaquer quelquefois en Descartes je
vais vous prendre les deux je vais vous
prendre le 7 mais ok je vois pas dans
quel monde les blancs sont pas mieux ici
on récupère
en plus j'avais aussi ce que je raconte
n'importe quoi j'avais aussi qui gagne
une qualité donc faut des quatre pouvait
pas être un problème je sais pas je sais
pas pourquoi il y a le jeu qui est B3
avant de jouer ces quatre honnêtement ok
bon
[Musique]
net comme un très bon coup de la part de
Chester
c'est le tueur de la position tout le
monde connaît des trois dans la
française à ce prix qui va souvent
sacrifier en H7 et met de belles
attaques
avec moi j'aime bien les blancs quand
même
j'aime bien les blancs
j'aime bien les potions dans la position
est intéressante ça c'est sûr elle est
riche effectivement il y a énormément
d'options pour les deux
à quatre à trois ou quatre ça m'a l'air
intéressant parce que Ben le cavalier a
pas beaucoup de cases je peux revenir
par là-bas et je gagne du temps dans
l'attaque donc peut-être ça et essayer
de faire donc à trois je dois proposer
c'est bien
il a fait
non B3 tu es obligé de faire parce que
si tu surras 3 qu'est-ce que tu veux
faire en fait si tu fais pion prend puis
on prend ça ouvre la colonne ça donne à
casbécane ça simplifie vachement quand
même pour les Noirs faut dire ce qui est
donc
je sais plus qui est fait tout le temps
et mettre un cava dans cette roche
serait une merveille pour les Noirs
ouais c'est ça et cahier des quatre on
est pas loin Kyle des quatre foubet 5
peut-être qu'il est 4 kb5
ça a pas l'air terrible mais
n'hésitez pas à nous à nous mettre vos
messages sur poser des questions sur
twitch et sur les chats YouTube on va
venir voir et Floriane qui dit c'est
aussi ça m'aurait perdant pour l'instant
mais ouais mais bon Magnus Carlson c'est
mauvais perdant
Joe McEnroe était un très mauvais
perdant Novak Djokovic et aussi très
mauvais perdant il y a beaucoup de mots
et perdants chez les grands champions en
fait
Zidane il mettait écoute boule aussi
voilà
il y a beaucoup de cette ce problème ce
problème d'être un grand champion comme
ça il faut vraiment avoir cette
détestation de la défaite ailleurs la
défaite et donc c'est vrai qu'il faut
avouer que parfois il y a des
comportements un petit peu
voilà
et
vis-à-vis ça marche
après je crois que même avec Nakamura
alors c'était très limite ce qu'il a
fait hier mais ça reste quand même dans
les
ça reste poli quoi tu vois il va pas
insulter son adversaire ou voilà j'ai vu
un joueur qui s'est fait ban de chaise
score mais je pense qu'ils ont
complètement raison
bon on va le nommer d'ailleurs de toute
façon il parle pas français c'est Joe
bavard
qui a fait qui a simplement
fait des
proférés des insultes racistes à
l'endroit de son adversaire après une
partie perdue il a pris un an de Ban sur
chetcom
voilà c'est mérité
bon c'était clairement
pour le coup
c'était très raciste c'était c'était un
tournoi normal j'étais à toi sur
cheesecom il commentait en direct sur sa
chaîne twitch et donc voilà il a perdu
contre un joueur chinois donc tu peux
imaginer le genre le genre d'insulte
qu'il a qu'il a qu'il a proféré voilà et
donc il a été ban un an donc voilà on
fait attention à ça et ça fait ça fait
plaisir parce que voilà c'est pas
acceptable c'est pas acceptable alors
des des trucs de
des trucs de mauvaise humeur et tout ça
même ça peut être amusant à voir voilà
limite Naka qui va attendre 20 secondes
hier sur l'adversaire bon ok ouais bon
c'est pas fair-play mais c'est pas c'est
pas l'insulte oui
on compare pas voilà mais après je pense
que voilà je sais pas bon disons que je
bave
[Musique]
c'est un joueur qui qui est comme ça je
veux dire
c'est un genre très brillant mais
après il s'est excusé mais il s'est mal
excusez-moi je trouve alors vas-y
raconte-nous je vous raconte sa lettre
il dit il dit
si j'ai pu heurter des gens je m'en
excuse mais en fait moi ce que je
comprends pas c'est tu peux pas dire au
lieu de ça tu dis je m'excuse en fait
je le pense mais désolé de l'avoir fait
quoi c'était pas c'est bizarre quoi
c'est la formulation j'ai pu heurter des
gens enfin depuis le problème c'est que
tu vois
c'est la formulation dit je m'excuse en
fait c'est juste c'est quand même
vachement plus simple quoi donc
c'est pas la formulation était étrange
il est très colérique quoi
ils étaient allés tous les deux en
débrief après la partie et c'était euh
tu dois l'avoir vu mais sur le plateau
c'est aussi ça le problème c'est aussi
le alors il y a la triche qui a un
problème mais aussi il y a la paranoïa
autour de la triche ah oui mais ça ça
c'est quand même c'est un gros souci
donc ça c'est sans problème c'est pour
ça que maintenant bah ils sont réguliers
un peu ça parce qu'en fait avec tout ce
qui est ce qui est triste donc c'est
soit IRL ou sur Internet et ben en fait
bon bah il y a le cas on l'a vu Tony man
hein que bon c'est pas si c'est vrai ou
pas mais dans tous les cas ça réputation
elle est maintenant elle est un petit
peu
entachée par tout ça et il y a eu des
cas aussi et même en IRL où il y avait
des gens qui faisaient des lettres
parce que tel ou tel joueur tricher moi
je me souviens avoir le cas c'était
comment s'appelait Mireille à sandou
championnat championnat européen il y a
maintenant
très longtemps il y a pas 10 ans mais au
moins 6-7 ans par là et elle avait
commencé avec cinq sur cinq dans le
tournoi mais bon c'est une veste avec
2003 quoi et elle était dans les
meilleurs joueuses européennes et elle
commence avec 5 sur 5 et toutes les
filles ont écrit une lettre en toute
signée en frère en disant qu'elle
tricher
et enfin c'est ouf quoi pendant un
tournoi etc tu as pas de preuves et
c'est juste parce que tu as perdu quoi
et en fait c'est vrai que
tu peux être sûr de toi etc mais à un
moment donné les arbitres
et en fait c'est eux qui vont t'as pas
le droit de toi ouais non mais
moi ça m'est arrivé aussi j'avais battu
un gars qui streamait
quelques années et j'avais juste contre
lui et comme j'avais dit streamer et ben
j'avais beau voir son stream tant que je
compte plus tu vois c'était marrant et
je l'avais mis genre 5-60 et
en fait à la fin des parties dès que je
triché et bah j'ai pas aimé quoi je lui
ai dit quoi et juste voilà donc c'est
vrai que c'est pas cool parce que tu as
en stream tu as du monde qui te regarde
et en fait tu sais pas si c'est vrai
dans tous les cas le mec en face qui est
qui est là quoi et ben tu lui tu lui
salit toute son image au niveau de tes
viewers sans savoir après
ouais pour deux ouais non bien sûr bien
sûr non mais c'est un scandale deux
choses pour parler de neiman et c'est
lui il a il a quand même avoué avoir
triché oui Dada énormément
quand même c'était quelque chose qui
était devenu
mécanique c'est-à-dire que voilà il a
triché pendant des sessions des
centaines de parties Blitz il l'avouer
lui-même donc bon déjà c'est un peu
c'est un peu différent
et deuxième ouais non mais c'est vrai
que c'est c'est des tests stable cette
ambiance on va jamais j'ai jamais eu ce
bonheur d'être c'est un peu je trouve ça
un peu mignon finalement ça joue
tellement mal qu'on va jamais accusé de
tricher je trouve quand même dernier
carton ta crise de tricher ça veut dire
que tu joues hyper bien en fait tu vois
et moi jamais et pas une fois enfin en
tout cas pas que je sache on m'a jamais
accusé ce qui m'a un peu tu vois je sais
pas je joue trop mal quoi en fait tu
joues trop mal tu triches pas on est sûr
que tu triches pas aussi on te connait
on sait que tu as un bon joueur on sait
que tu es tu étais j'ai ce petit
avantage de d'avoir été fort en fait
avant que les ordises soient forts voilà
il reste peu de place j'étais grand
maître à plus de 2600 avant qu'il y ait
des ordis quoi simplement enfin des
années 2000 ou alors c'était Fritz frise
2 que tout le monde battait en fait donc
c'est vrai que ça
ça enlève peut-être les les suspicions
d'ailleurs on parle de un arrêt lol en
plus moi je suis américaine
c'était là pour le coup c'était vers
après et c'est quand les passait maître
donc
comme ça et en fait à la fin de la
fermer et puis elle a fait une énorme de
enfin c'est un homme de mètres masculin
et l'entonnoir qui a lesquels tricher
en fait de partout sur le réseau enfin
bref et elle bah écoute non en plus elle
était en couple avec Salgado qu'un très
fort à remettre espagnol qui a plus de
2006 enfin tu vois à s'entraîner et puis
bon voilà quoi
donc c'est vrai que tu peux avoir des
doutes sur des personnes sur des gens
bon ok mais juste garde-le pour toi et
puis ça sortira mais c'est pas à toi de
faire justice et puis il y a des gens
qui s'occupent de ça et par exemple tu
as
bien sûr
il y a pas de problème c'est hyper bien
fait et là notre ami Jules il en
souffrance quand même hein je sais pas
ce que tu en penses te fous de corps
opposé quand même avec ses pions sur
noir là le pion E5 est devenu une vraie
faiblesse maintenant voilà on va jouer
il y a plus d'attaqueurs maintenant sur
le roi blanc sur le roi noir pendant on
va jouer G6 dès qu'il y a une meuf on va
jouer G6 et qu'on a tous regardez ce fou
si il apparaît en D4 avec les Noirs il
va taper sur 5 il va taper sur B2 il va
taper sur F2 aïe aïe aïe Jules ça serait
un désastre de la perdre cette première
avec les Blancs
donc il y a quand même de chance
de te reprendre des cartes sur un coup
essayez de faire pour prendre peut-être
et tourner un je sais pas si il perd ok
bon
travail ce que je sais chez Naka contre
l'accueil il est bien à les raisins
alors peut-être on fait un tour on fait
un tour chez Ali Resade après ma jauge
de l'ordi dit qu'il est il est très bien
allez
Laurent a pas gagné 150 points hellofid
en un an quoi
[Musique]
peut-être pourquoi pas moi j'y crois
voilà non mais non mais il faisait de
manière bizarre et effectivement
alors la solution qui a été dû enlever
son titre de Grand Maître effectivement
il y a aucun doute que pour l'avoir joué
Igor roses de nombreuses fois il y a
aucun doute qu'il a le niveau de Grand
Maître et il a eu son titre dans les
années 90 donc les chaises bases
n'existaient même pas les ordinateurs
n'existaient commencé c'était les
balbutiements des des premiers
ordinateurs donc
effectivement il a il avait le niveau de
grand maître alors il a gagné 150 points
un truc et puis il s'est fait d'ailleurs
il a pu jouer hein pendant pendant 1h30
personne n'avait de preuve bon il y a eu
après il y a eu cette fameuse photo il y
a eu les aveux
voilà bon là je crois qu'il est il est
suspendu il me semble je sais pas bon le
pauvre à l'histoire est compliqué enfin
le pauvre
c'est un truc c'était vraiment très
spécial quand même
donc
mais effectivement
la fille fait quoi sur Magnus Hans rien
il devait faire ils ont créé une
commission et comme c'est ça si vous
voulez enterrer un problème créer une
commission
c'est Roosevelt donc voilà mais ils ont
créé une commission et il donne des
délais donc il se passerait alors notre
Petit
Junior je suis désolé mais elle nous a
imposé en fait par cheesecom il faut
qu'on la garde pour le public
apparemment vous aimez bien voir un peu
il se passe donc c'est vrai que ça nous
permet de enfin nous ça nous aide à
avoir un peu ce qui se passe vraiment
dans la position et ça nous force un
petit peu à votre nous on travaille
vraiment sans ordinateur donc ça nous
force un peu à rentrer dans la partie le
fait d'avoir cette aide là ben ok nous
en tant que
que commentateur ben ça nous aide mais
surtout pour le pour le chat en fait il
y a des gens qui qui font comme toi et
qui sont très bons et qui veulent juste
essayer de travailler un peu l'échec en
tout en regardant le stream et il y a
des gens qui sont un peu moins fort et
qui ont besoin un petit peu d'être plus
comment dire
à diriger quoi et donc c'est vrai que la
jauge je peux pas te l'enlever
ça tenait qu'à moi je peux moi ça c'est
un choix éditorial de la garder en
partie rapide voilà ça permet de suivre
plus ou moins qui est mieux mais là ça
se voit les noirs sont pas mal
tourbé 8 fasse certainement venir oui on
a connu des gens qui ont acheté ici dans
les années 80 tout à fait casse pasta
alors qu'on a connu des équipes de foot
qui a acheté les matchs dans les années
80 aussi donc voilà ça c'est dans tous
les sports et c'est vieux comme le monde
donc il y a aucun problème enfin c'est
pas un problème disons propre aux échecs
d'acheter des matchs dans le sport bon
c'est vieux comme le monde je crois et
ça restera quoi que à mon avis ça va
être de moins en moins parce que tout se
sait dans notre société maintenant et
compagnie c'est un petit monde aussi
je pense que c'est plus compliqué
maintenant
ouais c'est un petit monde par rapport à
ça bon moment donné
steak nous c'est aussi un truc enfin
bon là tu parles d'acheter mais même
aussi
niveau triche et ben c'est tout vérifié
en fait ouais et dans d'autres sports
Las Vegas en 2008 son adversaire lui
parler avant la partie proposé je sais
pas quoi et Nakamura il s'est levé il
allait voir l'arbitre
ça rigole et pas la tête de son
adversaire que je ne nommerai pas ici
mais
la tête du type
il a dit c'est normal de faire on a le
droit de faire ça ou pas ce qui propose
l'autre est dans ses petits souliers il
dit j'ai rien dit évidemment il l'avait
dit qu'est-ce qui se passe et il fait
nul à les raisins alors qu'il était très
bien quand même ah il fait non de il
fait non ils font nul ok c'était tendu
quand même il était pas mal on va aller
peut-être voir la fin de
oups la fin de Jul il souffre Jules avec
ses fous de corps-posay il a perdu B2
malheureusement
j'ai récupéré ouh là là sans range 3 ça
a pas du tout une vingt contre 50
secondes
délicat des formes mais comme tu l'as
dit les fous de corps opposés faut
échanger les dames évidemment avec ce
roi faible en H3 elle a perdu un pion
même hein
il est moins bien mais
après ouais shimanov il peut faire des
boulettes en pour l'avoir joué dans le
playing dans le premier playing j'ai
fait nul la partie c'était n'importe
quoi dans le détail notre réciproque
la nul était faire tu vois en fait tu
vois c'est tellement n'importe quoi que
c'était impression de jeter une pièce en
l'air un faire un pile ou face et il y a
une huile au final mais c'est pas une
partie dont on pouvait être fier donc je
sais qu'il peut
il a pas la main ferme quand il reste
quand il joue sur le la crème
et rappelons que c'est du 15 + 3 donc
c'est très peu
logique dame D1 et Roger 2 c'est de dire
sur casse blanche peut-être
noir
c'est bien joué dame
et c'est pas simple 5 peut mettre un
coup hein un jour taper aussi
il est mal au temps tu vois il a 15 fois
d'imbé 6 ok sur F5 il va faire fou fou
recul donné aussi
mais pas de chaud
Ière
vous voyez les blancs
en plus
[Musique]
24 entre lui et mvl et devinez quoi et
ben Jules l'emporter dans ce match de
Bullet d'une heure un match d'une heure
de Bullet il l'a emporté face à mvl
c'est pour vous dire le talent du du
gars d'objectif
ah non il y a des meuf si ça marche faut
prendre F7 et c'est vu ou c'est
évidemment que c'est
un problème
je vous l'avais dit que shimanov il
pouvait tout lui arriver et tu ne peux
même pas faire dans mes chèques à la fin
parce que je pense sur un chèque en fait
et ouais c'est tout sur échec et oui
l'abandonne et oui c'est fait avoir
[Musique]
cette victoire je vous l'avais dit hein
il était pas il fait brillant en crise
de temps victoire de Jules Moussa
et on va voir donc il reste alors qu'une
seule partie dans ce dans ce danse le
match en fait vous savez que là on a la
poule déperdant et la poule des perdant
se joue en deux parties et en cas de
qualité et ben on aura le l'Armageddon
directement j'ai l'impression que les
gagnants arrivent plus tard oui des
gagnants en fait je l'ai compris sur le
slack parce que j'ai j'avais demandé à
18h je crois que ça commence à 18h mais
bon j'avais pas eu les infos on n'avait
pas on m'avait pas renseigné mais bon ok
c'est vrai qu'on a la dernière fois
c'était un peu comme ça aussi
ok donc très bien on se fait allez on
fait une petite pause et on revient 1-0
un petit peu des pubs vous savez qu'on a
des pubs à vous à vous montrer
à chaque fois plusieurs fois par jour
donc j'envoie maintenant et on se redit
dans 5 minutes alors
à tout de suite
[Musique]
pour le coup qui a pas du tout envie de
montrer ses idées pour un tournoi online
de partir rapide bon c'est s'il en a
déjà en plus sur la baignoire de di
carrous c'est pas c'est pas évident non
plus
mais
clairement
aucune ambition dans l'ouverture on va
voir comment il va jouer ici est-ce
qu'il va roquer ce qui va faire cavalier
afin d'abord pour mettre de cavalier en
G3 à la dame en E2 c'est tout à fait
jouable
r double pas trop les pions normalement
ici parce que c'est vrai que les noirs
sont prêts que c'est tout un fuite qui
sera qui aura une colonne semi-ouverte
devant elle donc en général on prend pas
on laisse prendre les Noirs mais même
pas même pas il fait pousser deux voilà
il fait pas des changes mais je crois
que des 5 va arriver
normalement le tarif il y a des seins
qui arrivent dans ce genre de situation
et salut à tous sur Youtube je vois que
c'est très animé sur chaise 24 en
français avec nos no modo oh là là la
maison est bien gardée c'était qui coule
Ouaga Merci à VOUS Tera
rendez-vous de l'après-midi n'hésitez
pas à mettre un petit like à vous
abonner à la chaîne et encore mieux vous
pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne
cheesecom en français sur YouTube sur
twitch voilà merci de nous suivre et
n'hésitez pas pour ne rien rater et ça
nous aide comme tu le dis ça nous aide
évidemment d'avoir de plus en plus
d'abonnés et de pouvoir vous proposer de
plus en plus de contenu
alors la question de loterie je vais pas
bien à comprendre
tu veux dire ça coûte rien de tricher
voilà il faut savoir ça le terrier 59
faut juste avoir un
complice en gros après c'est des moyens
technologiques tout à fait abordables
donc oui évidemment que
un joueur à ce niveau là il va
il va il va gagner de l'argent
clairement donc ça va être rentabilisé
très vite après ouais effectivement il y
a un risque c'est sûr mais comme dans
tous les bah il y a un risque aussi dans
tous les sports au niveau de l'image au
niveau de l'image donc
une fois que tu es pris et ben tu
trouves un autre jeu quoi tu vois un
autre passion ou d'autres affaires et en
fait est-ce que ça vaut le coup de
tenter même pour une somme d'argent de
tenter ça et alors que quand c'est un
compte à chopé en fait juste
par quoi
donc
avant de vouloir faire d'autres choses
et puis après j'ai envie de dire aussi
que vraiment si vraiment tu aimes le jeu
bon enfin normalement tu fais pas ça
a été éduqué comme ça on t'a appris à
bien respecter les règles et tout ça
c'est vraiment thème le déchet
ben écoute
[Musique]
normalement c'est pas dans ton éthique
de faire un truc une histoire avec après
on va on va changer de sujets
donc voilà c'était dans les tournois à
l'ouchta ou voilà c'était mon découvrant
de
et bien de d'acheter d'acheter ces
normes kaaki n'avait évidemment niveau
mais c'était juste pour battre le record
c'est tout et pour avoir plein
d'invitations mais il fait effectivement
ça a booster sa carrière c'est évident
d'être le plus jeune grand maître au
monde ça booste une carrière
et ouais il y a une article dans le New
York Times
donc c'est quand même assez
sérieux comme institution je ne savais
pas
mais bon après c'était un des un des et
en plus celui alors là pour l'instant on
peut dire du mal de caraquine sur tout
ce qu'il a fait récemment ça c'est une
certitude mais à l'époque
ben voilà il a 12 ans donc en fait
c'est plutôt ses parents son entourage
qui a décidé ça pour lui
alors
ok j'ai ça qui fait pousser 8 tout
simplement les carreaux pas très
impressionné non parce que fait alia il
va faire H6 simplement ensuite c'est
vrai que c'est pas très impressionnant
faut bien
faut bien l'avouer
je sais pas comment continuer ici
un truc marrant mais bon c'est pas
forcément très malin mais je pensais à
Dame aux deux et sur H6 sur H4
ouais c'est ça
rien du tout
[Musique]
je suis vraiment pas obligé de prendre
en plus oui en plus voilà c'est juste
pourg4
[Musique]
glorieux alors après puis on prend des
pas si clair cette variante en
l'occurrence mais bon ok
ça n'arrivera pas en tout cas
qui est quand même plus naturel
donc sur cavalier prend le 4 il veut
prendre en faire cavalier prend on
imagine mal comment la finale pour être
inférieure et on va simplement reculer
le fou c'est la partie il y a une prise
et
là on va attendre
le petit rock c'est tout étroit un truc
comme ça
on commence par foudre
bon pas grand chose assez
normal pour l'instant rien de fou fou
par contre c'est vrai qu'ici on a
on a Jules qui est contre shimanov qui
shimanov lui-même est en mustwin donc si
tu veux on peut avoir on peut aller voir
un peu ce qui se passe
avec les Noirs cette fois-ci
ça ressemble à la partie d'hier et ça
ressemble à la partie d'hier on peut
voir plus le début peut-être ce qui se
passe
qui est
différent de la part de shimanov
clairement
aussi c'est un joueur un streamer donc
il essaye pas de
de gagner dans les ouvertures mais
d'avoir une position
[Musique]
simplement un petit peu plus facile à
jouer
il va essayer de pas gaffer sur la fin
ça lui a coûté cher parce que d'une
partie où il était quand même bien bien
partir en tout cas normalement aucune
chance de perdre en partie longue et
bien ça c'est ça c'est affolé comme quoi
[Musique]
c'est toujours quelque chose
de difficile à gérer
tout à fait mais Jules qui le mérite de
pas se décourager et de jouer sa chance
jusqu'au bout clairement clairement je
pratique là
donc là il y a quand même ce vis-à-vis
encore de dame ça me gêne un peu
par exemple 5 peut devenir une menace
interne parce que si un jour je mange
d'une pièce et ben il peut y avoir une
découverte mais
à voir que surprise prise a découvertes
avec cavalier M6 pour manger comme ça
ben j'ai cavalier prend F6 merci je
défends quoi exactement pour l'instant
non mais ça reste dans l'air attention
ouais c'est une idée qui peut arriver à
un moment donné
ces quatre étaient joués ok bon du coup
petit système petit système de la part
de shimanov qui a l'air de très très
bien connaître
écoute c'est
quelqu'un qui a de l'expérience
clairement donc voilà il a ses petites
prépas
toujours un peu de la partie précédente
on le sent
qu'il allait un petit
mais bon du coup là de ce mini match
parce qu'on est dans la dans la poule
des perdants genre qui ont perdu hier et
en cas de en cas de victoire de de
shimanov on aura droit à un départage
par contre si Jules ne perds pas et ben
il sera qualifié pour le deuxième tour
des perdants et il va jouer contre le
gagnant de
Nakamura contre fearuza qui sont en
train de jouer à côté donc ils ont fait
une première nulle assez on va dire
tranquille dans la première et la
deuxième ça se dirige encore une fois
vers une position qui est qui est
peut-être nulle
et
bon je pense qu'ils vont faire un petit
départage en tout cas les deux ça
m'étonnerait pas que ouais c'est quand
même
ça commence quand tu me le dis tout à
l'heure mais je croyais que ça commence
ça commence quand le truc des vainqueurs
là alors peut te dire je peux essayer de
voir un peu les salles que j'ai non ils
m'ont ils m'ont mis là je peux pas
changer mais sale
[Musique]
ça doit suivre
c'était match je pense qu'ils vont ici
en tout cas moi j'aime pas je suis un
peu inquiète
je n'aime pas du tout la position de
Jules ouais
vis-à-vis tu as pas de place pour tes
pièces avec les Noirs donc c'est plus
dur à vraiment trouver quelque chose à
faire
donc en plus il y a moins de temps
répondu déjà donc à voir
salut les routes
si Jules gagne ou fait nul il rencontre
le gagnant de ikeruza
ou le parent du bracket de gagnant
enfin j'ai le tableau là je peux vous
dire exactement
alors ce qui va faire c'est que si
jamais
vulgagne bah je contrôle le gagnant de
de fille rousse de janaka ouais ça c'est
sûr et
c'est bien ça
il y a une grosse surprise avec les
défaits de simultanées je crois que
c'est pas clair en fait non je crois que
en cas de en cas de victoire je crois
qu'il va jouer alors c'est pas clair
tableau là que j'ai sur les yeux
il est possible que looser quand on
finale
oui je vois ensemble et en fait le
vainqueur de du gagnant de Jules et de
nakafiru et je vois contre donc on a
encore les grandes forest etc
mais ouais voilà donc le gagnant va
jouer contre l'autre là c'est ça c'est
clair
clairement
de elle a l'air et elle a l'air bien au
courant zoork mais moi sur mon tableau
mon tableau
vous inquiétez pas on va suivre tout ça
toute façon
et c'est pas aujourd'hui c'est dommage
la suite
en tout cas il y a pas plus de deux
matchs par jour ça c'est une certitude
qui était
emprise donc là c'est lui pour s'enlever
du vis-à-vis et carré le 5 qui attaque
quelqu'un pas mal de pièces chez les
Blancs
[Musique]
ça rend le cavalier en C3 un peu loose
comme on dit les trois il y a peut-être
B5 et sur pions qu'on peut pas parce que
ib4 attaque la dame et on va prendre le
cavalier C3 donc ça serait vraiment pas
bon il y a aussi un pion en prise en
décisif mais je crois que c'est pas
terrible d'aller le manger
parce que
cette droite directement
[Musique]
il faut trouver une solution avec les
Blancs
et si maintenant qui a fait un peu la
tête là je l'ai vu faire non de la tête
une mauvaise humeur
depuis cette malheureusement
c'est quand même pas mal pour Jules j'ai
l'impression dès qu'il va avoir une
décision à prendre et je pense que ça
soit à côté
salut rayonneu 2011
donc là j'ai du cavalier E5 ou du
cavaler à 5 et deux coups en l'air on
leur positive donc moi j'invite de
rester comme dans l'idée de faire
cavaler le sac ouais mais je prends
j'aime pas avec le cavalier
il est venu au moins 5 Jules ouais c'est
pas mal cavalier
c'est pas vraiment ce qu'on
ce qu'on voulait et sur Cavalaire des
deux
pas de dessin de trouver un truc
dame C7 j'imagine que cavaler des deux
dames c'est 7 on va voir torcer
et que la prise en C4 c'est un peu peur
avec le vis-à-vis ouais c'est même pas
sûr ouais tu penses que ça joue
c'est un qui est français
il me prend il me prend la tour mais moi
aussi je te prends la tour
en tout cas ça se calcule mais les
Blancs ont pas trop trop le choix je
pense que le jeu
c'est toujours pas cavaler les deux tu
perds le pion
et P3
salut chat 525 et sur l'extension qui
nous demande une
français c'est du racisme non si
critique les Français oui
c'est ça tu as le droit de dire
individuellement à la personne que c'est
un idiot mais pas c'est pas gros ça peut
pas être groupé voilà
c'est la différence on fait d'éducation
civique ici c'est bien
alors
comment on fait pour protéger espion à
trois à trois c'était quand même c'était
pas terrible
[Musique]
particulièrement mal joué oui tiens la
tête dans les mains
c'est l'élimination pour le coup pour
shimanov ouais
[Musique]
alors
pour pour être ici c'était déjà déjà
fantastique maintenant ben écoute pas en
groupe 1 tu as quand même que des
joueurs vraiment de l'élite donc c'est
très très dur
c'est très très dur et
[Musique]
on voit quelque chose de l'autre côté
des parents t'as Nakamura
voilà disons le clairement
ici
il a une position qui a l'air
intéressante
un petit peu mais c'est pas c'est quoi
en position s'est arrêté où on se taire
ouais il est à même fait exprès de la
paire de fou
et ça reste une position fermée se fout
en foot casse noire on sait jamais trop
si il va jouer ou pas
c'est intéressant c'est intéressant pour
8 ouais ouais il joue très très vite
très solide IKA una c'est son style
attention la position reste fermée donc
tant que ça permet la barre de feu est
pas si bonne faudrait qu'on arrive à
faire un peu le ménage au centre pour
que la part de foot soit forte
c'est pas évident de faire le ménage au
centre faire l'orange je t'ai vu jouer
tout petit au cheese master de Lausanne
oh là là quand c'est un tout petit je
sais pas si petit que ça
on était bien à Lausanne ah bravo et
bravo à Lausanne bravo Lausanne
un coucou amical à nos amis suisses qui
organisé ce magnifique young Masters où
j'ai joué et j'ai joué un joueur russe
qui était très méconnu à l'époque
s'appelait Alexander greatchouk personne
connaissait bon mais il est arrivé il a
gagné le tournoi en battant pour nos
Mario enfin battant d'abord à mettre un
peu de Mario Bacro on va attendre un peu
tout le monde sur son passage
mais c'est une belle expérience
en quelle année
99 août 2000 il y a 2000 la fois où j'ai
joué glitchouk et j'ai peut-être rejoué
ce young master c'était en 99 je joue
une fois une fois je me rappelle je veux
greatchouk je veux qu'une fois peut-être
ça
donc peut-être 99
99 je pense
il faut que
99 il me semble
909 j'avais 9 ans
quand même 17 18 ans
donc je pense pas
je pense pas que j'ai grandi autant
en
si peu de temps non désolé là ton
histoire elle est belle mais
alors
[Musique]
tu me confonds tu me confonds
j'ai
10 ans de plus neuf on va pas se
vieillir déjà que
c'est pas c'est pas brillant tout ça bon
salut à toi
je crois que ça a disparu d'ailleurs ce
tournoi Lausanne qui était un beau
tournoi l'Open comme le tournoi comme le
Young Masters de Lausanne où ils
habitaient les meilleurs jeux au monde
ils avaient fait
la formule de jouer les jeunes talents
contre les
vieux
les vieilles légendes quoi tu vois donc
on l'a fait dans ton club tu sais ça moi
je l'ai fait dans ton club va dans ton
club c'est ton club qui l'a organisait à
l'époque j'ai fait le match des
générations en 96 c'était à organiser à
Cannes par l'incroyable d'Amir qui avait
une enthousiasme
enthousiasme je sais pas pourquoi j'en
parle par le passé le fait en tout cas
quand il était à Cannes il avait cette
enthousiasme très très communicatif et
organiser ce truc là alors si je te cite
les noms des joueurs il y en a un qui
est pas mort voilà malheureusement
c'était corse-nord et Smith love
madniss Yves Coffe qui sont tous morts
elles sont en cours qui est toujours là
j'ai vu il a eu 90 ans sur son coup
il est en forme
et c'est souvent les échecs je pense que
ça conserve quand même ça conserve et à
l'activité intellectuelle
pour notamment pour Alzheimer
l'activité intellectuelle peut nous
sauver
ah tu sais la transmission sur Internet
OK
ouais
je te remercie
à peu près ça ouais mais c'était
love tu vois bon c'est ouf c'est bizarre
en 96 tu vois il était champion du monde
en 55 quand même c'est 40 ans plus tard
en fait tu sais même pas tu sais même
pas ce qui se passe peut-être pas 55
d'ailleurs peut-être un peu plus tard
et ouais donc c'était beau au Palais des
Festivals
des beaux souvenirs en tout cas
alors
cavaliers
en G6
ou en dessin que peut-être essayer
d'occuper l'espace
qu'est-ce qu'on doit essayer de faire
ici avec avec les Blancs est-ce que tu
on doit essayer de faire des quatre et
de balancer un petit peu essayer
d'ouvrir un peu le centre est-ce qu'on
doit essayer de faire un bon condition
mais j'ai pas l'impression que ça marche
parce qu'il y a tout simplement eux
prendre des quatre
[Musique]
on enlève le Pione d'écart déjà la barre
de fou elle va se faire
en quelle année Smith love pour voir ça
regardait s'il vous plaît moi j'ai
regardé parce que j'ai dit 55 puis je me
suis quand même dire une ânerie comme ça
et il se trouve que c'est pas si mal
c'est pas si loin
plutôt content je m'étais je pensais
mettre gouré de plus
je suis assez mauvais pour les dates
ça marche
très jolie
j'ai trois pièces et aucune DM ne peut
venir
empêcher la promotion donc et c'est
marrant dans la caméra de de lire ça que
des fois ils regardent à gauche et en
fait il regarde ouais ils peuvent se
voir
on peut se voir et là ben écoute les
gens sont malades
peut arriver et c'est un bel avantage
avantage blanc j'ai un paire de fou la
potion qui s'est ouverte et j'ai une
majorité de ce côté-là qui va pouvoir se
créer
est-ce que ça va passer comme ça en tout
cas malin le F4 qui est le 6 elle prend
le 5 je pense que Nakamura avait
peut-être raté elle prend le 5
peut-être qu'il pensait qu'il y aurait
de la MEC 2 après ça a pas l'air il y a
trois cinq aussi qui qui se regarde
et ça va
méthodique 59 vous êtes tous très
proches mais c'est pas tout à fait ça
qui est pas du tout proche pour le coup
faut réviser la
mais les autres c'est à peu près ça bon
c'est 57 58 il a gagné son match en 57
et il a perdu il a perdu en 58 je pense
que c'était contre
cette époque de Bonneville tout ça
contre qui il a contre qui il a gagné
deuxième derrière votre vinique
mode championne il a battu votre vinique
effectivement
et ensuite
en 58 je crois qu'il a c'est le seul
truc bonne vini qu'il a il a pris sa
revanche je pense
et donc c'était le septième champion du
monde des échecs
qui fait la gueule excuse-moi
d'attendre donc c'est un mauvais coup et
ben il a fait dans la tête effectivement
il y a bien
attention même quand il boude notre
amiaska il est quand même là il se
défend jusqu'au bout il va rien lâcher
et c'est vrai que la jauge met un bel
avantage on fait un petit un petit
chèque chez Jules tout va bien pour
notre ami notre ami Jules quoi que c'est
chaud quand même c'est très chaud mais
effectivement tu veux faire non mais là
c'est bien on reste sur ça évidemment
parce qu'elle est cette partie on peut
on a peut-être de futur vainqueur du
tournoi ici et c'est vrai que vu la
Jules il a besoin que d'une nul donc en
fait c'est un peu moins
chaud alors attends je vais revenir au
direct vu qu'il y a eu des coups qui ont
été joués mais pas chez moi
OK
on est bon donc avec 4
et si je prends 26
il va se passer quoi les cinq je suppose
et on essaie d'avoir du jeu mais ça a
pas l'air terrible
ça a l'air un peu tu vois
je vois pas mais comment
pardon pardon je voyais pas la suite
sur 6
mais bon tu as peut-être dame prendre
sur la
ou il fait non encore il est pas content
alors pourquoi
on va le voir où c'est simple
et
un moyen d'essayer de faire quelque
chose
c'est chaud en tout cas c'est chaud pour
tout le monde je trouve
c'est très chaud
comment est-ce qu'on passe
je pense à Dame C5 aussi mais
[Musique]
il prend son temps il a bien raison mais
bon attention moins d'une minute pour
une minute 20 encore pour aller Elsa
c'est très chaud parce que le retour du
roi alors les finales sont tout archi
gagnantes avec cette paire de fou et ses
pions ramassés à l'aile dame mais par
contre il y a un vrai problème sur le
roi blanc comment on fait
pour l'instant je vois pas de faut
essayer d'échanger ces dames
donc dame 5 on va avoir je pense qu'il
faut garder les pièces
je suis d'accord a l'air plus logique en
plus c'est introduit une nouvelle menace
qui est de cavaliers G3 donc dame 5
semble être vraiment le coup
mais comment est-ce que je continue
après
possible à cause de cavaluation de
fourchette voici
tout à fait OK
vis de loin
et il est pas content il est pas content
du tout
après il sait que lorsque se voit donc
il aime bien aussi je pense déstabiliser
un peu attention
un peu de maintenant
je suis l'adversaire
comment est-ce qu'on joue là
je pensais
que ça a l'air hyper chaud
finalement qu'est-ce que tu as qu'est-ce
que tu as fait alors B4 il a pas l'air
il y a pas l'impressionné car oui mais
attention vas-y à jouer derrière la
dernière seconde ça joue sur les nerfs
est-ce que vous prend un 4 et un coup
alors ouais ben ouais il encaisse hein
quand il peut encaisser car oui encaisse
c'est tout lui ça parce que j'ai jamais
été j'arrive pas à m'organiser il y a
des fourchettes de partout menace faux 5
menace faut 5 attention
mais là ça devrait être nul quand même
on devrait le peu de pions sur échiquier
quand même avantage la défense ouais
mais là
ça en l'air mais il y a échec échec
c'est quoi le problème c'est une gaffe
c'est une gaffe
voilà voilà j'ai 5 page 5
à [__] puis on prend et c'est mauvais
mais ça va être gagnant c'est moi ce
couleur mais c'est gagnant
mais le problème c'est que en fait le
fou doit sacrifier sur le pion B mais en
fait on va jamais laisser faire ça ben
écoute si il y a les Razak à titre
partie
et là Nakamura
h allez
écoute qui va mettre dehors à mettre à
la porte
icarbonate
encore des petits des petits ennuis
techniques alors je pense que c'est sûr
que c'est gagnant mais il faut quand
même roi des quatre on va être un fou en
D3 mais je vais laisser mon froid 8 et
en fait je suis trop obligé de donner H7
à un moment ou un autre
ouais le roi va être trop long
ça c'est nul il a joué cette regarde
la scène parce que il y a plus les
caméras hop là
c'est ça qui est très important à
comprendre parce que
là
et c'est nul parce que maintenant le roi
va rester en son coin et qu'il aurait
fait à l'IRESA
ouais
je pousse tu vas perdre depuis un je
vais mettre le fond à 6 mais je vais
être à temps avec mon roi je vais
réussir à te dominer donc on va voir on
va voir peut-être notre ami notre ami
Jules ce que ça donne Jules ça joue
encore ça joue encore
embrouillé dans le Zidane j'ai
l'impression mais il reste 10 secondes
chacun donc ça va être chaud il est Adam
il est à Dame Blitz
ça se passe bien pour Jules ouais ça va
être terminé on va avoir un choc des
franco-français là
voilà ça va être beau pour tout à
l'heure ou peut-être tout de suite
d'ailleurs on a on a Moussa RALI résa
oh là là ça va être
c'est Jules très très beau match à venir
c'est de jouer à se connaître très bien
et s'apprécie
évidemment
évidemment ils font de même des Bleus de
régulièrement ils discutent ils font des
Blitz donc bon évidemment allez résa
numéro de mondiale donc à lireza énorme
favoris mais attention
c'est qu'il faut se méfier de
Jules voilà il a deux pions il y a
aucune chance il y a aucune chance pour
pour shimanov il a bien les Noirs notre
ami notre ami Jules donc voilà il est
mieux
il va tenter quelque chose évidemment
mais il y a a priori rien à faire
ouais il y a vraiment rien à faire a
priori
donc là ouais ça y est on l'a on l'a en
plein écran ouais shimanov bon il joue
parce que nul ou défaite ça change rien
il est éliminé de toute façon mais
les bons cas sont quand même ce compte
sur les doigts d'une main
de faire dame B7
et ensuite on pousse le pion il y a pas
de raison de nous espions a
c'est ce qui va essayer de faire chier
man of de ramasser ce pion pour 4 dame
B3 qui empêchera pas
pour
les je vais vous dire exactement le
tableau pour les quarts de finale de la
poule déperdant et il va affronter alors
d'ailleurs on on avait tort par rapport
au au tableau alors je sais plus qui
dans le chat nous disait qu'on avait
qu'on avait tort peut-être qu'il pourra
nous le rappeler
sur les appareils
parce qu'en fait c'est bien ça
Jules il va affronter
le perdant je pense de carvana à torov
non je suis désolé ben regarde je pense
que j'ai
je t'envoie
non non mais là tu te trompes
je suis pas d'accord
à mon avis regarde ce que je t'ai envoyé
oui est-ce que tu m'as envoyé
c'est il joue ensemble
et il joue contre le looser de la
demi-finale
le vainqueur je contre le looser de la
demi-finale je crois pas ce que je t'ai
montré il y a une place au milieu allez
on va faire on va faire un petit Paris
parce que moi j'ai un tableau qui est
vachement plus clair
tu peux le montrer tu l'as le tableau tu
vas dans au lieu de partir tu vas dans
le résultat
à droite tu sais dans le secret division
1 tu vas dans un résultat tu vas en bas
pas les résultats moi j'analyse passage
un truc ouverture parti j'ai voté
malheureusement
si tu vas voir que le gagnant de i le
gagnant I qui est le match entre
icaru Nakamura
alors le gagnant I
ok non
regarde il y a gagné gagnant eux
gagnants eux c'est qui entre le perdant
h gagnant e c'est donc furusa contre le
perdant h comme h donc le perdant h
c'est c'est bien ce que disait mais
regarde ce que je t'ai envoyé
j'étais en bluff complet sans le savoir
donc le père Adam de complètement raison
ah oui c'est le match ah oui d'accord
donc le perdant de le perdant de cargo
Anna contre mon tableau va jouer contre
Ali resa le perdant jouera contre Ali
raisin donc c'est encore un gros gros
mal ça
et le gagnant contre le gagnant de vente
forest ecolark encore une fois c'est
c'est
encore plus puni et attends ça veut dire
que Jules il joue il joue le perdant de
Van forest colors ça va être heureux
en 2006
en étant sûr d'avoir raison en plus
je vais demander à juste s'il rejoue ou
pas ouais ouais demande-lui bon je pense
pas du coup parce que il devrait
attendre que le match et carronnage ou
donc je pense qu'en fait là on va
enchaîner avec Van forest colors et
Carona App Store et
donc on va voir les matchs maintenant
d'accord les matchs de la poule
de la grande poule
et je vais voir si je peux retrouver
mais ok il va venir il a interview avec
les Anglais OK et après ça y est ouais
ok
ouais il dit que après c'est magnifique
partie sont impressionnés c'est vrai
raison mais en tout cas vos tableaux là
du coup beaux tableaux et alors si vous
voulez en fait une petite pause 5
minutes pendant que
on va rappeler un dernier truc que les
copains et que dès qu'on a perdu un
match on joue des matchs en deux parties
c'est fini après
ouais ouais ce système a devis est très
chouette mais c'est pas le plus lisible
ça effectivement j'avais pas vu venir le
truc de faut attendre de perdre et tout
ça
donc on va voir tout ça on fait une
petite pause et on revient la caméra de
l'autre tournoi et c'est vrai que la
Jules il est encore sur le zoom il va
venir il va venir
donc à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme du retour avec Laurent et on a Jul
qui va arriver dans quelques instants
qui va nous rejoindre ici même
Jules qui a remporté son match qui
jouera demain pour suivre ses exploits
mais jouera demain donc contre le
perdant de collars van forest donc ça
reste quand même très très abordable
à noter l'élimination précoce de des
carreaux Nakamura bon on allait avoir
une surprise de toute façon avec
avec ce
match entre ce match de la peur entre
les raisins ferrugia et corona donc on a
Nakamura out c'est incroyable après
demain
il a gagné la saison dernière il nous a
pas du tout
habitué à ça en tout cas et ça montre à
quel point le niveau du tournoi est fort
franchement
sortir ma caméra de mature 2 c'est assez
incroyable
et on a car on a l'image donc ça c'est
le braquet des vainqueurs donc ça veut
dire quatre parties rapides du 15 plus 3
et ensuite en cas de partout on a le
fameux Armageddon à noter qu'il y a
l'autre demi-finale qui se joue en ce
moment même entre van Forest et collards
la demi-finale très très surprise
évidemment et ça c'est vraiment c'est le
combat des chefs clairement
va jouer contre le perdant de ce match
là alors dans mon oreillette j'ai Jul on
va l'accepter et il va venir nous
rejoindre d'ici une petite seconde
attendez
ne bougez pas
salut Jules
allô Jules salut ça va allô allô
mais je vous vois bien en tout cas
Laurent il faut que tu enlèves ton micro
sur
les deux trucs ça va pas le faire voilà
nickel salut
en plus
je le forme je les forme pendant la nuit
bon ça prend du temps mais
je vais quand même Stéphane ça fait ça
fait déjà quasiment 6 mois quand on fait
ça des cours du soir bon il fait des
progrès c'est bien tu as plus Magnus
alors bravo mon petit Jules bon ben le
tournant du match c'est ce point F7 il
s'est un peu autocloué là on est parti
et après il a complètement craqué avec
heureusement ouais j'ai senti quand il a
commencé à faire [__] des quatre et
secouer tout seul ouais c'était hyper
bizarre ouais là je me suis dit bon j'ai
vu F5 ce genre de pump je vous la wing
tout le temps mais en plus déjà tu peux
plus trop perdre
après je me disais pas que je peux plus
trop enfin je voyais pas non plus
[Musique]
on continue
je pensais qu'il devait faire de la
machine peut-être et puis
revenir en C6 peut-être faire des échecs
je sais pas ça doit être nul quelque
part forcément mais c'est toi qui est en
train de pousser en tout cas c'est moi
l'adversaire
je comprends complètement ce qui se
passe dans sa tête à ce moment-là c'est
que tu t'attends tellement pas à perdre
ouais c'est ça
tu fais plus gaffe et tu penses pas à ce
qui est une tactique et en plus il avait
plus de temps puis bon j'ai jeter un
petit regard là à la cam après MG6
je l'ai vu pas bien et bon
j'avais vu en avance un petit peu et
puis dame j'ai 5 tu prends tout sur
échec et en plus
montrer aux gens de quoi on parle de
cette fameuse 2e partie après
l'ouverture de la deuxième c'est plutôt
mal passé je trouve mais c'est très
simple j'arrive pas je comprends pas il
y a quelque chose que je fais mal parce
que c'est pas la première fois que je me
retrouve mal bah ouais hier déjà hier
alors
[Rires]
mais aussi contre Baki
au National au National la deuxième je
gagne la première avec les Blancs et la
deuxième il me fait un la même structure
et je me suis fait défoncer ouais donc
faut vraiment que je regarde ce truc
mais en fait c'est un peu comme Ding
avec ça ça roule Lopez finalement bon ça
ça arrive au meilleur voilà tu as mis en
fait tu sais c'est le genre de truc tu
regardes avec l'ordi dans tous les sens
tu dis bon tout va bien je vais pas
perdre de temps regarder ça et en fait
s'il faut pas faire parce que c'est pas
facile effectivement mais il a fait il a
fait un coup alors on va on va leur
montrer après à trois bons ça empêche
ouais bah si c'est pour empêcher c'est
pour j'ai compris
[Musique]
la première d'abord la première la quand
il fait F5 parce que l'autre fait une
grosse partie c'est la deuxième elle est
intéressante en vrai alors la deuxième
est intéressant la première ça c'est
jouer sur une alors
j'aimerais bien voir ce que dit l'ordi
d'ailleurs après après son C5
ouais à trois est une grosse faute donc
je sais pas ce qu'il fallait faire
exactement
à la fin c'est cavalier 2 par exemple
c'est hyper bizarre mais ça a l'air de
marcher pour les bras et vu l'état de la
jauge ça ça marchait oui j'ai vu que mon
cavalier ressort il peut pas le caméléon
peut-être mais bon j'imagine que je peux
faire fouiller d'eux ou quelque chose
comme ça j'en sais rien
peut-être je sais pas
bon en tout cas c'est
je sais pas exactement comment je fais
bon j'aurais trouvé un truc
j'ai 5 poubelles ou inversement enfin en
fait mais ça a l'air
je pensais
en fait
mais j'imagine que je peux faire
peut-être des trucs comme cavaliers F6
quand même non
ça va pas parce que ça donne la cassée
par exemple si je te fais on va dire fou
prends à trois rois G2 roi exactement
se déconcentre pour garder sa partie
il était mort de rire
comme d'habitude
je sais pas
j'ai fait Pione qui est peut-être une
faute
le champ libre qui avait dû prendre donc
en fait il menace qui est pas facile à
apparaît
pas à donner la qualité d'une bonne
manière c'est un peu dommage
mais du coup le plan c'était de faire
[__]
et là il a le coup fout des quatre et je
pensais avoir Kevin il prend B2 et en
fait j'ai raté un truc bête c'est qu'il
fait fondre
du coup je ouais j'aurais fait autre
chose je pensais faire du coup peut-être
fou prend quand même et juste pour C8
quelque chose comme ça mais c'était pas
le plan quoi c'est pas le plan de base
ça fait un peu peur avec toutes ces
cases noires
oui bien sûr
mais c'était c'est clair c'était pas le
plan parce que sinon je fais descendre
en fait ou le pion prend
et sur le BK
6 ou c'est 5 là je la donne à l'aise à
l'aise
je pense que j'aurais dû faire des cinq
si je vois ce truc en avance et après le
sacrifice là les deux Dom pour la
tronche je sais pas ce que ça donne mais
je pense que je dois être ok mais
j'ai pris quelques petits problèmes en
vrai on a c'est le moment de ton match
qu'on a pas trop regardé parce qu'il y
avait il y avait aliasa qui jouait
contre contre
il a gagné ça devenait très chaud et
c'est vrai qu'on était pas inquiet on se
disait au pire bon bah au pire il y a un
Armageddon non puis on savait que tu
étais pendant la partie à ce moment-là
je sais pas ce que ça donne mais il y a
des trucs à regarder type en fait je
crois qu'on s'est arrêté on s'est arrêté
un peu avant je crois on s'arrête
on s'arrêtait à cavalière 5 donc là
ça
je pense que c'est pas un bon coup parce
que je sais pas en fait
c'est un repose sur un petit truc
tactique c'est que bon en fait j'ai
peut-être un autre coup mais sur parents
il peut pas trop jouer pour bien parce
que j'ai B5 peut-être
[Musique]
quand tu dois gagner ça c'est pas c'est
pas évident un peu colère dans la partie
il était je pense la partie d'avant
qu'il a rendu un peu fou ouais ben je me
suis dit après avoir gagné la première
c'est pas facile de se remettre d'un
truc comme ça
qui est en train de pousser
mais bon après F5 il a commencé à
beaucoup a beaucoup prendre
[Musique]
je me voyais pas trop perdre
parce que j'ai toujours ce F5 qui va
liquider à fond je vais activer mon fou
bon faut juste que j'empêche du A4 mais
participer le temps de voir que firou
filou grosse partie à la deuxième
surtout une grosse partie italienne il
se place c'était compliqué mais
il a eu dans les notes
donc voilà il revient bien il y a quatre
raisons de sous par rapport d'habitude
sur les deux matchs d'ailleurs bon allez
ASA qui se refait un petit peu donc tu
vas jouer finalement
et en fait non non je joue un mec qui
vient du Winner Bracket
ah bon
en fait quand tu es dans le loser
bracket tu joues des mecs moins fort tu
es presque tu es presque tu es pas
avantagé mais bon ouais
le perdant de Van forest Colars donc
c'est largement
un tableau alors attends un problème
c'est que si je change ça va couper la
caméra je crois
j'y comprends rien au tableau c'est
juste regarder l'autre l'autre tableau
confiance
alors attends ce truc c'est quoi
le gagnant de
eux va jouer contre ouais par contre ok
d'accord
c'est du bas le perdant de de vent de
faux Colars et ben tu l'as joué contre
le gagnant de
de fille roux et contre le perdant bref
on se comprend mais j'ai compris
mais à priori quand même après même
Pirou il va jouer quand même contre le
perdant de carvana Abdou donc
ça va être ça va être un gros gros match
mais écoute c'est pour
ce match contre
[Musique]
deux fois pour être éliminé donc tu
grilles quand même un joker mais tu as
un tableau qui est peut-être plus
favorable donc bon bah dans tous les cas
c'est intéressant puis bon ce qui est
cool c'est que ce format là en fait
tu peux perdre je dois perdre deux fois
pour être éliminé et du coup ça donne
une chance et ça permet de faire de
faire plus de match donc ce format il
est assez intéressant finalement
[Musique]
il doit pas trouver ça super intéressant
de me retrouver dans cette situation je
veux dire c'est cool d'être là mais si
tu te prends 4 bulles en cinq parties
c'est moins marrant c'est ce qu'on en
pense de kerwana abdos à torov j'ai
réfléchi et je pense quand même que
Carolin est favori assez large en fait
en fait
je lui ai pas donné l'occasion de faire
trop d'erreurs aussi j'ai trop mal joué
j'étais pas tant du tout
on va voir moi je suis pas sûr du tout
match après c'est vrai que que le
dernier match fabille il avait quand
même fortune à car
il avait fait non il avait battu après
il a perdu ah oui il a perdu deux fois
ils ont fait un match chacun et après je
sais plus quoi il va il va tout le monde
aussi en ce moment il est hyper chaud et
puis même tu vois hier on en parlait un
peu de ton match contre Abdou qui me
fascine un peu chez lui c'est un peu son
attitude en fait devant l'échiquier il
est tellement sérieux c'est c'est
un truc qui me
bah ça on dit un peu long sur sur lui
quoi déjà tu vois le placement de caméra
la lumière tu sais que les mec il est
pas là pour pour enfiler des perles ah
oui
c'est travailler
c'est pas son premier c'est pas sa
première apparition
est-ce que tu penses qu'il a est-ce que
tu penses qu'il a apporté des affaires
ça valise qu'on voit sa valise un petit
peu derrière son bras je pense que
encore
ah oui il joue non c'est ça ouais parce
qu'il y en aka qui a dit qu'il avait
voyagé donc il s'est plaint hier sur
Twitter il a voyagé donc pour le Norwich
parce que c'est vrai que doit commencer
le 29 donc du coup si tu joues jusqu'au
26 bon mais ça fait un peu chaud c'est
vrai
surtout c'était loin donc peut-être
qu'il est déjà en Norvège il est déjà en
Norvège je crois que j'ai vu un truc
Abdou aussi
dans un hôtel avec sa valise à côté
c'est possible
et la position va vous en pensez quoi
moi je pense que les noirs sont ok je
pense que ils ont trop de jeu en tout
cas ces trucs là c'est toujours hyper
dangereux avec les Blancs
j'aime pas ça
comment tu trouves une répétition de
coup ici
à Fougères
[Musique]
mais ce que je comprends pas c'est en
fait le seul problème des Noirs ici
c'est ce pion à 7 on a on peut pas jouer
tout A8 qui serait le coup normal à
cause d'un prince quoi que
voilà on a ses pions faibles mais le roi
blanc
après le roi blanc comment tu l'attaques
parce que le pion est en deux ça ça
sauve complètement les blancs parce que
s'il était en E3
F2 serait plus faible
si je fais un coup comme je fais un coup
comme dame 8
j'imagine que je dois faire ton C21 pour
faire quelque chose
bon là j'ai c'est ce que je peux jouer
beaucoup
de vision de la vie
ouais je suis un peu moins bien
j'arrive à tenir un peu les pions ça
doit être nul mais bon c'est pas le
c'est pas le beau jeu il fera passer
dans la position
de départ
la dame à 4 qui tape sur G4 aussi ça
peut un moment j'ai appris ça d'abdu
hier
non je trouve ça très dur à jouer pour
les Noirs effectivement ça a l'air OK au
feeling ou là
ça a l'air OK au feeling mais
[Musique]
il y a quand même un problème de je vois
pas comment je vais en fait
faut essayer alors est-ce que tu
recevrite
pour faire
un truc du style
et c'est d'organiser ces cinq mais
on imaginant que tu peux pas bouffer à
cette tout de suite
ou alors à l'ancienne
et en fait c'est sur j'ai vraiment voilà
tu as ton tour
je suis curieux en fait de voir son père
ah oui ça protège le pion comme ça
maintenant si tu fais tourner admettons
tu auras 8 maintenant
mais tu me laisses toujours passer
simple
j'ai pas trop de casser ça mais si tu as
envie je pense ici quand même
si je prends le 2
allez vas-y vas-y je sais alors vas-y
pour honorer
effectivement donc j'ai pas j'ai pas
c'est pas la bonne question peut-être
prendre les cavaliers F5 mais c'est
vraiment parce que tu veux je pense
je sais qu'il faut que je garde les
dames et que je sais que c'est
surprenant mais il faut que je garde les
dames et que je tomate c'est dans la
position en tout cas mais intéressant
très dur à jouer moi je trouve
c'est pas sûr à 100%
mais je pense que ça va pas aller
et donc c'est quoi l'idée d'ams2 qui est
C4
je sais pas si on prend l'exemple
[Musique]
puisque c'est ça
c'est tellement famille de jouer F3
incroyable est-ce que c'est concret quoi
c'est pour ça que moi je vois bien tout
dans ce match
ouais après avoir
c'est la partie parce que Abdou en plus
il est quand même il va montrer des
ouvertures enfin
des petites idées il prend ça au sérieux
je peux te dire que tu sais que c'est le
premier arrivé sur zoom il est là une
heure avant
toujours hein parce que je l'ai vu
plusieurs fois
alors cavalier 3 ou cavalier A3 kb5 mais
salaire 3 artificiel ouais surtout tu te
prends du jeu sur G7 potentiellement un
carré de 3 c'est la partie prise
c'était pas ça son plan c'est ça la
partie est surprise il y aura toujours
deux hein
on va avoir une partie
3 mais bon
je peux faire tout reprendre
pour huit
je voulais faire une espèce de ah j'ai
même plus on prend en fait ok tout fait
nul
je pense ça va
encore plus facile
est-ce que c'est pas les blancs qui
poussent du coup
ça c'est sûr
des seins comme tu le disais le roi F3
qui est quand même pas mal actif forte
et là il peut pas faire tour C3 et F2
un petit peu ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
par contre là je change de scène et j'ai
pas du tout ta caméra donc je vais la
remettre un petit seconde 1 donc en tout
cas on voit vous avez la partie c'est à
23 est-ce qu'il y a des blancs pendant
que je mets ta caméra
en fait
le monstre
alors est-ce que c'est si clair que ça
permet de voir des joueurs un peu
nouveau
en même temps ce qui permet quand même
délimiter pas mal de joueurs candidats à
la qualif pour la division 1 ouais mais
ils ont joué attends
et sont qualifiés d'ailleurs ils sont
qualifiés et au final
pour le coup
mais oui c'est très sympa de voir des
joueurs voilà comme comme toi comme
Collard comme shimanov voilà qu'on voit
vraiment comme yorden aussi en fait le
problème
qu'il est capable de très bien jouer en
rapide il joue pas terrible franchement
ouais mais si il est capable aussi
attends
je crois qu'il avait juste perdu contre
Magnus mais il avait battu plein de
champions
je crois il avait fait un super-pouvoir
enfin il est capable de quand même qui
est très original qui qui est très
dangereux
la différence entre nous on va dire bah
là les quatre les quatre under on va
dire
vis-à-vis des quatre gros c'est que nous
on est peut-être capable tu vois sur un
match ou même sur une semaine peut-être
de bien jouer mais eux c'est la
régularité
même si Nakara a pas l'air
c'est la première fois que je vois
perpendante
les voyages le fatigue je sais pas si
c'est vraiment
il est pas chez lui il est il y a le
décalage horaire
on sait pas dans ce qu'il a voyagé bon
après c'est pas une excuse hein
[Musique]
il va avoir il va sur ses 40 ans donc il
y a un moment où ça va quand même
descendre c'est résultats c'est clair
on va voir et Collard cela il y a il est
en train de gagner en fait
peut pas te permettre de faire pour
Tours
alors tu peux peut-être essayer un truc
comme ça
[Musique]
avec un pion qui a filé
franchement j'ai pas vu les parties
d'aujourd'hui mais j'ai regardé hier
soir je me suis regardé une partie de
charge up c'est quand même un open on
n'a jamais vu un open aussi fort
effectivement
[Rires]
[Musique]
donc ouais ouais effectivement à
Gibraltar il y a quand même de très très
gros prix effectivement il y avait au
moins je crois 25 ou 30 000 pouces
et les parents ça fait combien d'euros
donc ouais donc c'est ouais c'est assez
impressionnant et il y a des joueurs qui
jouent à division 2 ou 3 qui jouent à
charger aussi en même temps
ouais mais d'ailleurs on a reçu un mail
comme quoi il s'était pas très content
qui est autant de jeux de playing sans
pouvoir jouer au caout parce que là
c'est bizarre ceux qui sont à chargeurs
il y en a plein qui ont joué
alors c'est ça
dans les années 2000 effectivement tant
que
Jul n'a pas connu mais que j'ai bien
connu ouais j'ai joué aux flottes
beaucoup de fois 2002-2003 2004
puis tu avais les locaux russes en plus
tu sais les types qui sortent jamais
mais qui jouait enfin tu vois
il savait jouer une petite question pour
Jules avant qu'on le laisse
y aller
juste c'est quoi le programme après ça
alors toi 7 évidemment 7 on sera
boxing
[Musique]
ça va être génial
on va commenter aussi le chest boxing 4
matchs à partir de 18h venez si vous
êtes pas loin c'est dimanche et ensuite
on s'en va parce que dès que on s'en va
et on va au Top 16 à Chartres
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire le programme
Coupe du Monde Coupe du monde et
champion de France c'est ça non je joue
le tournoi fermé bien avant tu joues
bien d'accord
qui qui joue d'autre
je sais plus exactement mais c'est un
truc du style baloquant qui est toujours
là
Erica easy gamer je crois Bogdan Navara
voilà donc et c'est quoi c'est un mixte
entre partie classique partie rapide et
blides c'est ça ouais et puis il y a un
autre truc je crois le 960 et en 960 je
crois quelque part
d'accord ok mais génial donc bon
programme et ensuite Coupe du Monde et
France pour des fentes titres mais c'est
pour ça c'est pas mal aussi de jouer ce
truc en ligne ça entraîne un peu à
l'esprit Coupe du Monde quoi avec
effectivement ces éliminations directes
toute façon c'est l'esprit aussi de
enfin clairement c'est ça plaît ça plaît
au spectateur en fait donc si ça peut au
spectateur ça veut dire que ça va
devenir de plus en plus communication
directe donc il faut s'entraîner à ça
c'était pas une surprise
et Jordan est complètement foutu
moi je vais regarder ça
donc touriste de jouer peut-être tu
redonnes demain c'est à quelle heure
demain c'est
[Musique]
ouais c'est même heure à 17h je crois
alors
pour demain
très rapide on n'a pas on n'a jamais
assez on a peut-être joué une fois mais
au loin honnêtement peu importe là donc
c'est pas
[Rires]
et non mais faut signaler attends c'est
pas fini parce que il joue quatre
parties
vraiment que ça repasse à quatre par
contre ça passe plus jamais à 4 une fois
que tu as perdu ok une fois que tu as
perdu c'est à deux enfin je suis encore
une fois hyper sûr de moi j'en suis
convaincu mais je peux me tromper je
pense que c'est je pense que tu as
raison là
en fait tu me fais tu me fais pas du
tout confiance
j'ai la même avec toi je crois que c'est
comme ça donc
[Musique]
mais non je peux pas confiance mais je
crois que c'est ça
a gagné bon oui c'est terminé et même
merci infiniment et puis merci beaucoup
à demain
bonne chance pour demain en tout cas
merci et puis ben merci encore d'être
passé merci à vous à bientôt bonne
soirée
allez les survenu ouais du coup très
sympa Jules comme d'hab toujours hyper
cool et donc là on a on a
le premier match
du match des gagnants qui se terminaient
avec une victoire une victoire de
Collard c'est un contrebande Forest et
une nulle entre Kawana et ab12 autorov
donc maintenant on va avoir on va avoir
la revanche qui va arriver dans quelques
dans quelques minutes donc est-ce qu'on
fait une stage de pub Laurent allez on
fait une petite famille
je vous montrerai les
photos des images qu'on a de Carlsen qui
l'a fait avec un nouveau partenariat
avec Puma donc une nouvelle chaussure
vous allez voir franchement elles sont
elles sont vraiment sympas et donc je
mange une nouvelle photo d'ailleurs
Laurent peut-être à la fin de la pub
j'ai deux photos
je voulais mais maintenant et après la
pub
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une première partie très intéressante on
a vu le style très concret c'est ce
qu'on disait Jules très concret des deux
joueurs où ça a pas peur de rentrer avec
l'application de jouer des coups F3
alors que le roi est quand même pas
super safe mais ça calcule ça calcule ça
calcule et voilà donc un peu un
équilibre de la terreur dans cette
première ou partie très complexe mais
nul les escargots tactiques qui sont
terminés par une nulle tout à fait
logique mais ça joue fort on sent que
on sent qu'il va pas falloir cligner des
yeux d'un côté ou de l'autre la moindre
erreur se paiera cash et on a la
variante waouh tout ça torov qui joue
tout ici mais je peux vous dire j'ai
passé pas mal de temps à la regarder
cette variante je peux pas en dire
beaucoup plus mais c'est notamment cette
ligne qui a été jouée entre la partie la
plus connue de 2022
la partie vague du scarsen contre Hans
neiman
donc
il y a plein de coups les blancs sont un
peu bloqués dans cette ligne normalement
mais à 12h30
et bien alors c'est un coup j'ai jamais
vu mais je suis pas le seul apparemment
Fabi a l'air très surpris aussi il y a
pas le son à ce qui paraît
on est mieux
que moi-même mais je parlais pas
par contre toi ton son n'est pas encore
ouais je parle normalement ton micro est
bon mais comme j'étais mieux que
moi-même peut-être que si je suis mute
donc voilà donc cette partie elle est
dans la première partie très très belle
partie avec vraiment
deux joueurs fin tacticiens qui s'était
arrivé par une logique clairement et
donc
et donc voilà cette deuxième partie donc
cette fameuse partie animal c'était le
même début Tourer qui un coup que j'ai
jamais vu perso alors j'ai essayé de la
faire enfin j'ai beaucoup
passé pas mal de temps à regarder cette
ligne
et donc Abdou cette offre qui n'arrive
jamais les mains vides et sachant que
c'est une ligne que Fabi a aussi joué
avec les Blancs il y a quelques années
donc assez impressionnant alors après le
coup la jauge en tout cas montre un
avantage noir donc parfois c'est ce
qu'on peut faire en partie rapide un
petit bluff
si c'est dur à trouver pour les Noirs
pourquoi pas
ça se tient qu'est-ce qu'on fait ici
Stéphane à ton avis on prend ces trois
on joue à 5 on joue au 7 il y a beaucoup
d'options très honnêtement
je saurai pas trop pourquoi
il est pas pas d'accord mais un petit
peu
il devait compter sur ça d'où ça t'aura
fait là donc clairement Fabi qui est
surpris parce que il fait pas d'erreur
s'il est préparé
et juste
vous prendre cette fois c'est peut-être
le critique non
mais c'est vrai qu'on va on va faire le
4 avec les Blancs et puis voilà
comme d'hab c'est compensation de
catalane intéressante
la paire de fou
donc
quel était le coup cette fois ça
peut-être X5 était le bon coup mais pas
évident pas évident de jouer à 5 dans
ces situations là
vous étant légèrement mal placé bon il y
a toujours le courage sur un tournoi
donc ça peut être intéressant mais bon
c'est une décision pas facile à jouer
des 6 assez rapidement les joueurs
cherchent aussi à ne pas se mettre trop
mal autant trop vite
et damacat il va récupérer ce pur en C4
donc E5 est la condition continue à Sion
pardon normale
ah mais tu perds pas à cette
si je prends
parce que l'idée ça serait pas de
prendre à 7 en bout de course pour prise
en 5 d'abord
ça j'en sais rien
ouais
pour les noirs
tu te fais des faiblesses c'est pas
trois par exemple vous prend C3 je joue
au plus bête prend ces trois MF6
j'attaque F2 j'attaque j'attaque C3 bon
c'est quand même
j'ai aussi des idées avec tout reprendre
vaisselle d’apprendre cette fou des cinq
je vais accueillir le 5 ensuite et je te
pose des questions quand même assez
désagréables sur ton sur ton roi
notre appel prendra fin en 10 minutes
mon cher à Stéphane je suis un peu
inquiet
mais on a on n'a jamais
oui parce que c'était pas un appel de
groupe parce qu'il y a pas on était deux
je suppose j'en sais rien
on trouvera le moyen de se rappeler
on a nos 06 alors qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé il a joué quoi Fabi sur damacat
alors il y a eu
5 qui est la réaction quand même assez
logique qu'un réaction ensemble
et c'est pour ça qu'il y a le foot de 6
il veut vraiment jouer là-dessus
du coup elle se comprend
c'est logique de manger
là et puis même après on n'est pas
forcément de manger à ça
mais la position qui a l'air quand même
de
ça peut venir un peu
tout simplement
comment on peut faire je sais pas
peut-être que c'est le coup
du matériel pardon surpuis on prend des
quatre qui prend des quatre on garde
quand même le centre on n'a pas pris en
peut-être fouger 5 aussi qui est dans
l'air
ça peut être un peu désagréable pour les
Noirs ça clairement
avoir en tout cas c'est la partie
[Musique]
il y en a l'autre demi-finale l'autre
demi-finale qui se joue entre colase et
Yander van forest colors qui a gagné qui
a gagné la première partie je veux aller
voir rapidement
très intéressante
c'est colors
on est parti dessus
vous avez les parties à l'écran
non pardon pas encore là la partie est à
l'écran ah ça c'est une Sicilienne avec
la fameuse
c'est hyper dangereux ça position
et
les quatre cavaliers
ouais c'est une variante très thématique
avec l'idée de d'éviter à schnikov
et le live répertoire
attention on peut faire des C4
maintenant c'est que tu vas me prendre
B2 mais en tout cas Jordan qui essaye de
l'idée c'est si on bouge le cahier sur
une case par exemple cavalier 3 hier
normal il y aura x 5 quoi qu'il y a
fubéca tu vois même ça ça marche pas ok
donc non
mais c'est pour montrer ce genre d'idée
faire d'être comme l'adresse du roi
et là
on fait
ça peut aller très vite des deux côtés
voilà c'est ce qu'on disait encore une
fois c'est un exemple
qui est
assez intéressant
mais on sent qu'il est potentiel en tout
cas et c'est une position qui est
intéressante parce que votre Forest et
il a perdu la première donc elle est
noire et il doit essayer de gagner donc
la pagaille c'est
intéressant dans son dans cette
situation
on va voir un peu ce qui se passe
alors qui demain il joue le perdant de
l'autre match ça sera un très très grand
match allez ça jouera le perdant de
abusa torov karwana donc quoi qu'il
arrive une affiche assez formidable
parce qu'il a il a perdu le premier
match contre
le perdant de Abdou karwana donc c'est
encore une fois pas un cadeau
donc
[Musique]
du coup il va être à 200% sur ces matchs
c'est peut-être mieux qu'il ait des
joueurs vraiment je pense qu'il est très
difficile il se concentre plus
performant dans les matchs ils sont
réellement intéressants en fait
parce qu'hier est un petit thé il a les
ouvertures tu as vu la lapine qui avait
les G8
donc voilà
[Musique]
qui était sur le chat YouTube j'avais vu
on s'allume nos amis évidemment de
YouTube vous pouvez aller sur chaise 24
fress comme fr n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à mettre un pouce bleu
et même sur la chaîne twitch comme ça
vous ne ratez rien et en plus
et en plus vous êtes notifié vous êtes
notifié à chaque fois ça nous aide voilà
allez-y alors dame Descartes qui est une
énorme gaffe d'après la jauge pourquoi
alors
[Musique]
c'est sûr ça marchait pas l'air
pourquoi c'est pas bon
comment est-ce qu'on punition c'est
normal
ouais mais tu vois quand il met comme ça
rouge moi j'ai plutôt envie de punir du
coup
clairement donc je sais pas un coup
comme grand rock peut-être
quand c'est une croix rouge je crois que
ça veut dire que c'est un gain raté
de mieux pour les Noirs à
quasi perdant ouais mais c'est pas un
point d'interrogation ou de point
d'interrogation comme d'habitude là
c'est vraiment un bien raté mais bon oui
c'est mauvais aussi je crois que c'est
le truc
ça veut dire rien rater ça pour eux
mais ok oui
un truc pour les blancs quand même ici
tu fais kb4 j'ai poussé trois non
et puis on respire en grand coup comme
d'hab alors vas-y on va calculer ça nous
on peut bouger les pièces c'est ça
l'avantage ça me prend ces quatre F2
alors avant le roi E2 dans cette
position c'est complètement normal ça
fait le juste c'est là c'est l'ouverture
qui le veut
mais après les pièces noires sont pas
bien sortis et il y a quand même des
trous de partout chez les Noirs donc
c'est une position qui est complètement
folle
F2 je pensais déjà terminé
au roi des deux oui dans ta maison
et oui oui c'est ça Croix-Rouge chez les
pros ça prouve que tout le monde tout le
monde fait des erreurs et oui et à la
place
[Musique]
c'est très très compliqué très dur
en fait
c'est très compliqué
c'est assez compliqué
même ça par exemple je fais ça
je pense que
c'est très compliqué mais après encore
une fois c'est hyper concret
donc ça c'est mais c'est pas c'est pas
étonnant que que les joueurs en fait des
erreurs dans les positions aussi
compliquées c'est du rapide
il a joué quoi là
ce qui est mal au temps attention il y a
déjà trois bonnes minutes de retard
autant attention aussi en noir ah oui
non mais la position est très compliqué
mais attention pas trop trop si tu
bouges le cavalier concrètement ce qui
se passe si vous jouez il y a fou ces
trois et [__] F6 donc c'est perdant
donc il faut trouver une autre solution
soit contre-attaquer
soit clouer le pion genre x 6
ah on a été coupé
ok donc
on est toujours là ouais je suis là je
suis là on est toujours là on est
toujours sur discord mais on est plus
sur le je vois plus ton écran mais comme
je vois j'ai la position sous les yeux
donc ce que je disais c'est que faut à 6
mais bon ça a l'air très artificiel de
clou et comme ça parce qu'on menace rien
donc c'est déjà complexe à l'employeur
donne qui est évidemment bien au temps
mais attention
ça peut très très mal tourner ce genre
ce genre d'histoire
alors je viens de t'envoyer ouais
de nouveau le lien
donc là oui
mais ça fait pas plaisir à jouer un coup
comme fois si c'est si je te fais par
exemple grand rock je me souviens de
bouger la dame
tous ces trois filles avant non
c'est ça le gros problème de la position
noire
c'est comment on fait
en tout cas qui qui fait un peu la
grimace elle vient de faire des
mouvements de tête là il est pas content
c'était pas un super coup en fait
d'amener 4 jours à tempo si tu peux me
partager ton écran top s'il te plaît
en fait on s'appelle sur deux cols mais
ce qui me partage pas à l'écran
voilà merci beaucoup
ok comme ça je peux admirer Jordan
on va voir Abdou allez au revoir
en fait
il a été
mais maintenant c'est un pion de plus
bah écoute maintenant tu as les compense
parce qu'il voulait pas
et puis tu as tu as pas mal d'activités
et la dame qui peut qui peut attaquer
aussi genre E3 tu peux penser
malheureusement donc ça marche pas
non non
c'est pas ça pas très évident pour
famille
et quand quelqu'un contre quelqu'un qui
calcule aussi bien que nous ça torof
attention il aime pas ça Fabien en plus
avoir un pion en donner un pion comme ça
dans le désert c'est pas son genre il a
pas eu trop de choix là il s'est fait
avoir
donc une bonne réussite pour cette
partie un truc
ça prépare super bien marché une fois de
plus il est incroyable cette table d'où
cette Europe on voit qu'il bosse
énormément parce qu'il a des idées
il faut absolument tout
et il a décidé dans toutes les
ouvertures donc ça c'est
incroyable c'est impressionnant à ce
niveau là il a eu la chance entre
Guillem enfin il a la chance d'être le
compatriote de rouge steam Kassim Janov
qui est a commencé à travailler avec lui
il y a un an ou deux ou cinq Cassim
Janov qui est un très très fort grand
maître ancien champion du monde
individuel bon alors c'était c'est donc
il est pas vraiment d'un lignée des très
grands champion du monde mais il a gagné
ses cloques out ce qui veut dire que
c'est quand même un excellent joueur et
qui a une expérience de secondant assez
phénoménale notamment avec Vichy à
Nantes dans ses vaches champion du monde
ensuite il a eu il était secondaire King
pendant deux ans et il a travaillé qu'à
Rouana justement son adversaire du jour
pendant
5-6 ans donc ça s'est terminé mais
maintenant il est son nouveau poulain
c'est nord du bec abdosa Toro
donc l'influence de Roustam bah sans
surprise elle est elle est excellente et
en plus il a l'air de lui-même beaucoup
beaucoup travaillé
donc
c'est c'est parfait en plus
en plus de tout ça et j'ouvre très bien
et calcul très fort c'est dur de voir
des points faibles alors Jules avait
peut-être repéré en finale c'est
possible je sais pas
j'ai jamais j'ai jamais creusé plus que
ça pour essayer de voir ses points
faibles
mais ça serait pas super étonnant
après encore c'est un peu logique
que les finales
mais bon ok il a tout un grand mais tu
vois les mais je te dis même latitude en
fait ouais ouais c'est ça ouais aussi
aussi très aux Olympiens beaucoup de
gens le comparer à ce fait apparemment
ce qui est connu casse pas off
bah disait qui se comportait comme lui
dans les c'est vrai qu'il y a pas eu de
célébration il aille très sérieux il
perd pas de temps au repas enfin et en
mission notre ami Abdou
et puis tu vois c'est toujours propre en
fait même pour moi le voir à chaque fois
sur toutes les caméras de tous les
événements bah je trouve que même chez
lui enfin tu sais c'est carré quoi tu
vois c'est clean quoi
partout des sacs une bouteille de yoga
master à côté
c'est vrai que c'est assez
ce que m'a dit il va te call of qui
était leur entraîneur aux Olympiques il
m'a dit il est incroyablement sérieux
donc
bon écoute ça paye
que ça paye un autre aussi sérieux
parce que bon bien sûr du monde
j'imagine et il est encore jeune il est
encore beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
faire mais en tout cas c'est un sacré
j'avais joué encore il était venu jouer
l'Open de je crois qu'on a déjà parlé
l'Open de portique mais pas impressionné
mais il était vraiment très jeune en
fait c'est ça je m'étais pas rendu
compte en fait il y avait vraiment
2018 je dirais alors
simplement 13 ans donc il m'avait pas
impressionné mais il était déjà grand
maître avec avec 25 et quelques donc en
fait c'est impressionnant mais je savais
pas réalisé qu'il avait tout simplement
13 ans
c'est pas une grosse partie quoi c'est
pas deux grosses parties mais en fait
effectivement
[Musique]
j'avais plus pas gagné à cause de moi tu
vois où j'avais vraiment mal joué enfin
on a tous les deux mal joué quoi et mais
c'est vrai que j'avais pas réalisé qu'il
est 13 ans effectivement je pensais
qu'il avait 15 16 ans et bon j'avais
plus je trouvais pas ça
mais effectivement il a fait des
il a fait plus j'ai régressé là il a
progressé
[Rires]
pendant que tu parlais mais je crois que
ouais
je prends
et à la fin je prends le cavalier donc
on liquide un peu tout mais en fait on
va pour faire plus simple on va éliminer
la dame qui défend cavalier avec cette
série de d'échecs il y a une découverte
mais là me prend des quatre mains et qui
attaque un peu toutes les pièces il y a
plus de découverte donc d'abord on fait
fou prendre un V2 échec bon si il bouge
l'Europe c'est encore mieux alors on en
casse une pièce mais bon on va d'abord à
manger là on mange d'abord les grosses
et après on mange le petit plus petites
pièces
voilà
ça fait et il se développe et cette
fille avec le énorme pion de moi pour
Fabian en difficulté
dans tous les cas tu as F2
[Musique]
donc c'est bah ouais c'est beau tournoi
à jouer en plus l'expérience de jouer et
vraiment agréable parce que c'est du 10
+ 2
et donc tu peux me le streamer je pense
ah en fait
non je pense pas si vous essayez de
partir sont cachés
[Musique]
mais bon ok il gagne alors gagnant
sécurité il y a eu des cas de triche ou
des trucs comme ça avec des
en tout cas ouais non c'est une belle
expérience de jeu parce que tu joues
fait du 10 plus 2 tu as un affran tu
vois et tu rentres dans ton truc et moi
je trouve ça bon j'ai joué deux fois ça
c'est pas bien passé mais
ça c'est je trouve je trouve que
l'expérience de jeu est quand même très
agréable voilà mais regarde par exemple
là nous on fait la partie bon on a le
lien VIP mais sinon on va pas la suivre
mais si je veux je me le redis quoi
en fait tu es obligé de prendre ouais
non bien sûr bien sûr et du coup le fait
de mettre les parties en privé de demain
il y a pas d'arrangement par rapport au
prix pas par rapport à mais pas tu sais
pas ce qui se passe à côté donc tu peux
pas te retrouver et puis en plus ça
empêche peut-être qu'il y a eu des cas
en fait c'est que maintenant bah ils
sont obligés ils sont réduits comme ça à
cause à cause de des problèmes qui a pu
avoir encore une fois la triche une
masterclass abdosa Toro
et faire ça à carvana c'est c'est pas de
là tout le monde quand même
il fait une Master Class qui est aussi
se masturban a aussi qui a envie il y a
4 à 5 à 6 à 7 et salut à toi zylanzone
salut à tous ceux qui qui arrive sur le
stream venez vous manifester venez
parler avec nous venez poser question
ou ou quoi que ce soit n'hésitez pas en
tout cas à nous parler on est là pour ça
c'est un truc que vous me comprenez pas
s'il y a des questions à poser
à Laurent donc il y a plein de sujets
vous savez que sont favoris c'est parler
de de la sortie de son
[Rires]
[Musique]
en tout cas Abdou il nous fait il remet
pas demain ce qui peut faire aujourd'hui
il est il est impressionnant
après on peut toujours rater oui non il
peut rater
il y a des joueurs qui ratent plus que
d'autres et c'est vrai que lui
généralement quand il est gagnant ben
gagne quoi enfin c'est assez
dans la poche des 8 faut jouer mais
quelle horreur
mais bon
à 5 à 6 je t'envoie ce que je veux faire
ça
je sens pas en forme aujourd'hui
[Musique]
en direct alors que Van forest était
Colars ça joue encore je peux voir un
petit peu de loin là
écoute on est bien sorti
je dirais bien que j'aime bien en fait
incroyable on ira voir après comment ils
sont sortis
on va voir si comment il termine notre
travail à
8 seul coup alors
je peux même jouer sur foot88 je peux
faire le coup à 6 tour à 7 cavalier des
4 pour lancer 6 avec le cavalier et ça
va être complètement fini je touche F5
aussi en même temps ouais c'est quasi
abandonnable cette position il y a eu
des coups
qui est des quatre tours des cinq encore
et tous ces quatre
même aussi ça est tombé 7
en plus ça va se heurter à tourbé 7
ok prends vite aussi
j'aime pas le seul truc que j'aime pas
faire c'est qu'elle prend des 8 parce
que ça rentre en finale de Tours c'est
la hauteur tu as vraiment les seules
chances de nul ouais
il est vraiment horrible donc il prend
que si vraiment tu as vu un gars forcer
quoi exactement
ça déjà en tout on attaque F5 attention
alors je vais prendre du faux je prends
du Fou
ok ok
ça tu manges de quoi là
elle pourra jamais être
en 8 encore plus fort c'est
ultra propre ce qui nous fait
tourner
tu pourras jamais empêcher même qu'elle
va laisser six six qui est très jolie
ouais c'est le coup qui a été joué coup
brillant on voit l'ordinateur qui l'a
mis en bleu turquoise et ouais c'est
surtout reprends
rapidement
on y va on y va on y va allez c'est la
partie donc on sait pas comment on est
sorti mais
j'ai l'impression qu'il est complètement
gagnant en fait il est complètement
gagnant c'est sûr
il avait l'air quasiment cuit mais
c'était compliqué comme on l'avait dit
ça restait quand même une position avec
pas mal de
pas mal de tension
voilà il est
c'est juste perdu
[Musique]
elle a assez assez facile à gagner
tu finis pour qu'on essaie
quelque chose comme ça depuis on passe
lié
c'est trop
on va voir je suis curieux de voir ce
qu'il va choisir Jordan
il prend un H4 il prend le matos sont
les pions qui partiront pas attention à
chaque qui est perdu maintenant sur
échec en plus
ça abandonné et bravo qui revient alors
comment il s'en est sorti alors attends
il a été réduit au seul coup donc
c'est vrai que potentiellement les noirs
on le sentent maintenant et la paire de
fou ça peut devenir très très bon pour
les noirs
donc un parcours entre Collard c'est et
il leur donne van forest tandis que ça
torov mène un demi-0 et demi il va
falloir que Fabi vaut mieux qu'il fasse
quelque chose dans la prochaine avec les
Blancs parce que ça va être compliqué
dans la dernière avec les noirs
ok bah écoute parfait parfait parfait
est-ce qu'on part un petit pause pour
aller micropose et on revient ouais on
revient allez à tout de suite
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour avec Laurent pour
la troisième partie de la poule des
gagnants entre Caravana et abusottorov
donc abstenant qui vient de faire une
partie Master Class un contre carvana et
donc mettre maintenant un et demi à 0 et
demi au score donc un match qui est
assez serré et Jules tout à l'heure qui
était sur le stream disait que il
donnait car voilà favoris
et pour l'instant bah écoute
un et demi 0 et demi en faveur de
santorov
très prometteur il a encore une
Française tout à fait ouais il a préparé
la française clairement et voilà on voit
cette ligne un petit peu étrange avec ce
fond A4 mais qui est quand même embêtant
on peut pas jouer à 4 déjà avec les
Blancs et jouer x 3 ensuite et c'est
vrai qu'il y a spion C2 comme tu viens
de montrer ce pion C2 qui va faire
toujours surveiller alors effectivement
on a plus d'espace et il envoie tout à
l'américaine kerwana il envoie F4
intéressant évidemment il va jouer à le
roi clairement
alors G4 mais en tout cas il y aura 5 ça
c'est quasiment
quasiment certain parce que quoi d'autre
finalement
quel autre rupture tu as avec les Blancs
tu as pas beaucoup d'autres donc il va
essayer de jouer F5 mais pas évident
sans trop s'ouvrir surtout que les Noirs
ont a priori ils vont jouer grand rock
il y aura de le roi de l'autre côté et
le roi est quand même assez safe de ce
côté là
c'est complètement impossible le roi il
est ouverte mais pas t'inquiète ce côté
là et la colonne B bah en fait la tour
est toute seule quoi donc je peux pas
attaquer avec une seule tour
et dans descendu hein
d'être le coup complètement standard et
normal
toucher aussi
en contrôler 5 avec la dame par rayon
donc voilà on contrôle trois fois F5
déjà avec le cavalier le pion et la dame
ça rend la poussée plus difficile mais
j'ai quatre et on va tout j'ai 4
cavaliers
rock on sait pas trop si on veut mettre
le roi ou pas en G1
parce que les Noirs aussi des fois ils
ont même des ruptures eux-mêmes avec
le but c'est d'ouvrir la position
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ce roi blanc ma
ville Laurent
c'est vrai que je sais pas je vais
manger 3 parce que c'est pas bon
je suis je suis embêté peut-être en D2
il protège C2 et il est là il libère la
dame il a l'air quand même assez safe tu
vois tu peux pas trop ouvrir au centre
que le petit rock enfin l'Europe de
manière générale l'échec
c'est hyper important il faut le faire
tout le temps mais dans ces positions de
françaises
des fois où vous avez des coups assez
assez marrant et qui prend des deux ou
trois décès d'ailleurs il y a eu enfin
un petit peu une mode dernièrement avec
des coups des coups droits un peu de ce
type là on a vu plein de roi des deux
rois des 7
plein de fois c'est logique
et puis ça va ça paraît en fait bien
alors Dame des deux
c'est la partie et
[Musique]
ça m'a l'air chaud au final
dur dur ce beau jeu
dès que tu vas ouvrir il y aura le roi
derrière c'est ça le c'est ça l'ennui
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai mes je
m'étais
je m'étais auto autosens G3 et j'avais
préféré des deux au final mais là ouais
donc il part par là quoi que en même
temps il peut toujours changer d'avis
après c'est toujours compliqué de
changer d'avis
il faut changer d'avis là
on peut se permettre de mettre le roi en
G3 parce que la position est fermée
par exemple dans une position ouverte
naturelle mais dans la française on voit
quand même assez régulièrement sur deux
noirs les morts beaucoup aussi le roi au
centre
c'est standard
c'est pas du tout il a fini depuis un
moment il a battu et quand on a qu'à moi
il est éliminé car unakamura et oui
c'est pas mis ça et Jules Moussa à
éliminer shimanov bon alors
effectivement ils ont cet épée de
damoclass ils ont plus le droit à
l'erreur ils ont déjà grillé un joker
et un pas de joker donc prochaine
défaite ça sera l'élimination mais bon
ils sont toujours là donc la victoire
est toujours possible
alors doublé tour sur b pour les blancs
ouais mais ça amène ça amène nulle part
doubler tour sur B le pion B6 il est
solide comme un roc on va pas bouger ce
pion de A7 on va simplement protéger et
par contre il va il va probablement
doublé sur F nord du bec Abdou satorov
il met toutes ces pièces vous voyez au
max clairement il est prêt pour tout ce
qui va se passer à l'aile roi
pas très évident pour Fabien
je tourne trois ok un jeu de manœuvre
qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire est-ce qu'il
va faire coulisser le orange G2 celui de
H2 un truc comme ça sur mon
et de joueurs connaissent les plans ça
c'est une certitude
mais
voilà toi
j'ai deux il va mettre le tour où est-ce
qu'il va être notre tour de H en F1 ou
en G1
en fait pour les A5
[Musique]
je pense qu'il va vraiment sécurisé
l'aile Rome maximum et après tout
balancer
[Musique]
merci c'est le problème
donc pour froid c'est à 5 je comprends
pas
à 5 honnêtement j'ai pas la référence là
c'est trop bizarre
ce que j'ai 6 ou pas
impossible en tout cas il pose des
questions
à notre jeune ami à bout c'est
[Musique]
2730 à 18 ans quoi
on serait pas étonné que l'année
prochaine il soit pas loin en 2008
c'est pour moi c'est le joueur que je
trouve le plus
talentueux dans ce petit groupe de
jeunes qui poussent là ouais alors il y
a Ali resa qui est déjà un joueur établi
qui est quand même
il a tellement il est tellement fort que
en fait
on considère pas comme un
champion vu quand même un futur espoir
parce qu'il est numéro de mondial quoi
alors que ben ils montent comme les
jeunes hein
tu en as plein comme ça et après il y en
a qu'une particularité c'est vrai que ça
te refaire un peu un peu en avance sur
les autres de 18 ans et Google ça a une
particularité d'avoir deux ans de moins
il a simplement 16 ans goûte donc il est
aussi moi c'est mes préférés Google de
ce petit groupe là je les trouve
vraiment vraiment très très
impressionnant et vous cache à cette
avantage d'être plus jeune tout
simplement et tu vois on a vu l'idée de
faire à 5 pour jouer cavaliers à 7 et
ensuite kb5 et on va toucher le pur à 3
et alors peut-être qu'on veut pas le
prendre peut-être qu'on va le prendre on
va toucher le pion c'est trois aussi en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que les
Blancs devront
ils réfléchir
donc c'est une sorte de diversion et on
va être obligé d'immobiliser au moins
une pièce pour protéger tout ce beau
monde à l'aile dame
3 ok il se met dans le vis-à-vis avec le
waouh il fait qu'il y avait 5 quand même
il se fait pas bluffer tout un et ouais
voilà c'est ça vous voyez on est obligé
de ramener cette tour pour protéger le
pion
il va bouger le roi voilà il fait roi si
ça enlève du vis-à-vis du faux F3 et il
y a Faby vas-y promise
et franchement c'est pas évident
est-ce que kaij ici c'est un une option
ou pas c'est ça que je me demande depuis
tout à l'heure et prendre les 6 puis on
prend les 6 tours 7
est-ce qu'on a gagné quelque chose avec
les Blancs j'ai pas l'impression en fait
et j'ai même l'impression que le pion en
G6 il peut être faible mais quoi d'autre
pour progresser dans cette position
ça va être compliqué
je vois pas
je sais pas si quelqu'un voit dans le
chat n'hésitez pas donnez-nous un plan à
parcage
ouais alors le
ouais je te remercie qui pas 46 moi
aussi j'y crois
il y a déjà eu résa dans du bec oui
c'est sûr qu'ils ont déjà joué alors pas
dans ce tournoi mais il y a déjà eu des
matchs alors effectivement
[Musique]
ils ont bien dû jouer hein c'est sûr
mais je pense pas qu'ils aient beaucoup
de parties à leur actif
ouais c'est possible qu'ils avaient pas
beaucoup parce que
mais ils vont avoir ils vont en avoir
parce que maintenant ils vont être
ramener à jouer dans le même dans le
même tournoi quoi
maintenant que a franchi vraiment un
gros palier je pense que ça va ça va
arriver en croise 6 a été joué dans
cette partie
et
c'est pas trop comme ce qui va se passer
un peut-être que toi sur long terme il
va aller bouffer à trois quoi
mais bon je sais pas
les blancs ils poussent là-bas
qui est ouvert
et en plus je suis assez
je suis assez
près de plantes à la main en fait bon
les Noirs pensent qu'ils vraiment ils
améliorent leur position au maximum tu
vois parce que je pense pas que son but
c'est vraiment de jeu pour faire nul je
pense que juste si il joue des coups et
ils préparent sa pollution au maximum
mais comme ce sera vraiment près
d'ouvrir ben il ouvrira quoi donc c'est
pas
solide quand même pour les Noirs c'est
vraiment bien sûr mais c'est pas parce
que les petits coups que forcément
je pense pas que ça
[Musique]
la main ah oui à ma main elle reprend du
pion c'est marrant ça moi j'aime pas
ok mais j'aime pas les ce5 mais
je me dis en fait je te demande parce
que franchement là je suis pas je suis
pas sûr non je pense que les deux
possibles ça dépend de la réaction que
tu veux faire derrière ce que tu veux
faire 5 est-ce que tu veux faire F5
sinon je veux faire non mais non je veux
faire pion prend qu'il décide F5 et
mettre un truc
moi j'avais la même idée
on prend F6 c'est que ça mes tours joué
plus beaucoup après
ouais et là on va voir peut-être un long
terme aussi une idée qui pourra pour
ouvrir un peu plus la position pas pour
l'instant mais là on décide et essayer
peut-être de passer mais c'est pas
simple même quand tu joues qu'avec ce
pion qui peut aussi être un peu faible
mais
est-ce qu'on peut mettre la pression sur
F4 un jour plaquer la qualité peut-être
pas de suite
il pointe là il pointe là attention les
vis à vilain
en tout cas tu vois franchement
et alors là tu peux manger à trois alors
à trois dans peut-être pas de manger il
y a d'Ham c'est un peut-être
je sais pas si c'est possible il y a ça
pardon je pense pas
c'est deux pour calculer tu en prends un
cap 3
c'est comme ce qu'on avait vu tout à
l'heure avec Jules ouais ça fait quand
même beaucoup de pions
trois pions pour la pièce et le roi qui
est quand même assez
c'est faible
il y a eu
et qu'elle va les prendre à trois c'est
un coup après je pense pas que son style
bon il a assez concret c'est vrai
mais il est pas obligé de se presser il
a un point de plus ouf on parle mais en
fait lui il s'en fout complètement il
balance tout
ça
je bougerai la tour pour
je sais pas pourquoi pour faire
concrètement si jamais tu as pas grand
chose je fais un cabanon 5 moi aussi au
fur et à mesure je peux essayer de
trouver du lieu mais bon il y a toujours
ça en l'air aussi et vraiment des
positions compliquées je peux manger là
manger là
et
il calcule pas qu'il ne sentent pas quoi
je sais pas je sais pas quand le va se
terminer cette partie mais si à Google
c'est parti le match est terminé je vois
pas je vois pas de nul honnêtement vu
comment
j'ai commencé ça se déroule je sais pas
quoi j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont là
dans un match de boxe Facebook sing
c'est le chesboxing avant l'heure
il y a cette ce pion et tu vois
qui vont tomber en fait la pièce blanche
sont toutes mal placées il y a pas
d'harmonie mais après regarde un
cavalier en M6 un autre cavalier en D6
un cavalier en E4
ça peut aussi ça peut aussi faire peur
clairement
c'est hyper chaud mais bon je pense que
Caroline elle est pas mécontent d'avoir
cette position parce que bon ben il faut
qu'il gagne quoi donc au moins ça il y a
quand même un
oui bien sûr monsieur pour lui c'est
bien mais
matériellement il a une qualité de plus
pour un pion mais au moins voilà lui
cherche des positions un petit peu
j'ai pas le mot
déséquilibré déséquilibré merci tu as
besoin de toi des techniques des cours
d'échec et
des fois
[Musique]
ça m'arrive en espagnol en fait je parle
à la maison je parle espagnol et du coup
je
j'avais plus de mots français j'avais
mon espagnol je n'arrive pas à le dire
en français c'est je perds mon français
alors la position elle est méga complexe
mais ils savent qu'ils ont besoin de
temps pour peut-être plus tard un moment
qui sera peut-être décisif donc on peut
pas se mettre trop mal au temps je sais
pas là ici le coup qui me vient cette
dame C7 pour faire pour protéger G7 mais
c'est qu'il y ait des six cavaliers aux
quatre
voilà c'est des variantes qui peuvent
venir ici et
attaque G7 et c'est vrai que ça peut
être
chaud c'est chaud ça c'est pas envoyé de
le faire
jeter un petit coup d'œil chez Van
forest Colas
ouais alors c'est intéressant mais bon
c'est ce match est trop on reste on
reste sur Abdou là parce que là c'est
quand même c'est qu'on va des chefs
c'est intéressant je dis enfin je dirais
la jauge surtout tu préfères la vie de
je suppose que tu préfères la vie de la
jauge que le mien la jauge dit que c'est
un tout petit peu mieux pour les blancs
bah j'aurais dit
pas claire tu me parles devant toi
mais rien n'est fait clairement
et on a cette partie qui est quand même
passionnante avec ce roi H3 va-t-il le
regretter il pourra s'en rend B2 notre
ami famille
mais bon il est pas si mal hein H300 ça
gagne des finales
ça se fait mater aussi parfois toujours
pareil
alors ils gardent ce
kibb5 fois 4 ça construction à la dame
qui est bizarre qui prend rien mais qui
immobilise la Dame des deux et la tour à
1 sur la défense du pion A3 des pions à
3 et 3 donc c'est intéressant mais d'un
autre côté on peut pas les faire jouer
ailleurs qui manque des pièces un peu
hein en défense aussi et que
va être jouée alors j'ai l'occasion de
faire cavaler cette puis fou des sept
puis cavaler les 5 je pense que je le
ferai
la même avec le avec le cavalier enfin
que le foot sortie c'est que ce fou il
sert pas grand chose le fou il bloque la
dame en ces deux mais sinon à part ça
il y a un tournant que tu auras là on
menace
et c'est une gaffe donc
tu prends ces deux après enfin la finale
mais bon le problème
il faut calculer ça quoi ouais mais je
crois que ça a rien il y a une grosse
[Musique]
très important sur ces deux c'est pas le
plus procéder c'est le fou qui revient
sacrifier là je vais faire tout prendre
j'ai cet âge
c'est complètement fini donc
c'est probablement ça le coup
je prends à 4 je prends et je te prends
le pion g et ça vade ouais je suis trop
lent en fait ça va
une
erreur donc là je vais quand même
plusieurs coups c'est pas forcé de faire
encore bon cette fois ça va perdre
instant parce qu'il y aura ton investi
c'est et puis qui qui va trop vite
histoire de pas acter peut-être pas de
faut penser de 5
professionnel on va on va enlever tout
le contre le jeu avant de pousser le
pion h ouais et
ça se retournerai non je pense que Fabi
là il est mal calculé
abdossator off alors c'est dur de crédit
c'est une décision rapide qui l'a prise
mais bon
c'est dur de dire c'est génial
je pense en fait je vois pas de quoi
tu vois un coup non qui prend ces trois
on va le montrer simplement
pour 3 et et la vadrouille est terminée
tu reprends à 3 qui prend des deux on
prend un 4 rideaux
fini
les pions qui qui poussent là
mais même la courir 5 en fait
non
4 non
B4 je prends un 4 je prends ton pion g
de Tours géant autour recette je sais
pas je fais quoi
c'est fini complètement on reprend en
retard plus mon pion et moi je vais
sacrifier ma tour tout simplement
c'est fini
il a été trop confiant là
il a son petit regard qui balance des
fois sur la caméra enfin sur
il y aura
la tête de Fabi était ratée
et ben c'est rassurant
bon ça va faire un point et demi un
point et demi au bout de trois parties
on va avoir une quatrième partie
très importante qui pourrait mener un
éventuel partage armagidon
ça c'est ce qu'on avait dit ouais ça
c'est trop facile pour pour Fabien il le
sait Fabi comment ça se passe chez
mauvais coup mais ouais bon enfin un
mauvais coup ça se sent il y a pas de
bon coup
je m'en fous n'importe où
non mais bon il y a les pions un peu
passé en fait tu vois il y a les pions
il compte sur ça
ça c'est la même sauf que
je fais roi C3 et j'essaie de refaire
[Musique]
non on est complètement d'accord
c'est terminé on va aller voir Jordan
peut-être qui est complètement gagnant
contre Collard ok alors là ça peut
mettre fin du match
ça peut être fin du match
[Musique]
comment je finis là
pour des deux
[Musique]
alors on va le montrer
ce qu'il veut c'est la finale comme ça
au même en fait même si bien d'ailleurs
moi j'ai vu la finale je dis bon ok mais
bien évidemment mais aussi
assez joli surtout qu'on a cinq ou
prendre les cinq suivis de full 6 vous
pouvez cette fois et la dame est
inévitable
qui a eu il a mangé là autour des 8 ah
ok ah jolie jolie jolie on va avoir un
abandon de Collard cela tu prends je
prends et je mange le fou
et ce sera parti perdu
malheureusement tu as pas de cachette
avec toi
inévitable ok on retourne sur sur rien
il va abandonner
on va pas trop
mais c'est pas si marrant peut-être
tomber en l'air sympa ton verre safe roi
c'est 5 fous prends des 5
cadeaux
ça rigole pas
alors roi C3 à mon avis le seul coup
pour continuer
un tout petit peu la partie
[Musique]
exactement
à 4
[Musique]
français 4 a l'air complètement gagnant
vous pensez qu'à trois points C4 tours
F4
roi B5 seul coup
tu as tombé trop là qui gagne facile
enfin je veux dire il peut encore
arriver un truc
donc là je vois pas d'autre coup que
c'est ça
et là on menace rien on a B5
à trouver quand même
c'est fini depuis un moment mais mais
écoute j'ai encore toi et c'est quoi ton
camion mais
il faut il faut encore le battre quoi il
faut être précis vraiment jusqu'à la fin
quoi à ce niveau là jamais en paix quoi
une position que j'aurais abandonné
depuis bien longtemps parce que j'aurais
pas vu toutes ces ressources bien
évidemment tu crois pas en fait de tour
de moi enfin tu as une tour de moi
mais bien sûr c'est gagnant pour les
blancs
avec peu de temps
là
ou pas
tout de suite non parce qu'il y a je
prends je prends tout avec le fou mais à
trois d'abord
ça marche pas là mais
alors il faut ramener le roi pour
s'occuper des pions
[Musique]
j'ai pas de malheureusement un torrent
B3 puis on prend puis on prend il faut
prendre abondant
abondant ça me fait marrer pas bien
partout c'est pas une partie que tu as
la ville d'avoir une sorte de quasi
forteresse avec avec deux pièces de
moins enfin douter quand même
donc voilà donc là
car voilà qui revient au score à un
point et demi maintenant
un point de nuit un point et demi donc
il reste une dernière partie entre ces
joueurs pour se départager en cas
d'égalité enfin en cas de match nul dans
la fortune partie et ben il y aura une
une partie en mode Armageddon donc on
vous rappellera un petit peu
ce qui se passera en cas d'égalité et
par contre s'il y a un autorité d'If et
ben ce joueur sera qualifié pour je
crois que travailleur la finale il me
semble
Laurent oui la finale tout à fait la
finale contre
la fin enfin pas le vainqueur mais
effectivement c'est la finale du la
finale qui permet d'être en finale
attends d'attendre d'attendre la finale
qui permet d'être en finale et
d'attendre le que les ceux qui ont fauté
une fois ceux qui ont perdu une fois
sans trop tu et voilà quelqu'un aura le
droit à la revanche il avait été en
finale il avait fait la finale de la
finale contre la dernière il a perdu
deux fois c'est ça c'est ça
intéressant on va voir si fabir vient en
tout cas si Abdou ça te revient avec une
idée là dans cette partie ouais c'est
très et les blancs il va tenter quelque
chose c'est évident
allez dernière pause je pense dernière
pause et on revient et on revient à tout
de suite bonne journée ciao tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour oups ta caméra
qui a
nous sommes de retour avec deux matchs
passionnant ce match des ce choc des
titans entre Fabiano corna et nordi
Beckham première partie nul deuxième
partie victoire masterclass de Abdou
satorov et 3e partie
archi complexe avec une victoire de Fabi
qui se relance dans ce match mais alors
ils nous font
un match de folie les deux tandis que
dans l'autre match
la deuxième demi-finale peut-être la
demi-finale surprise entre Dimitri
chocolat le grand maître
allemand et Jordan van forest Colars a
gagné la première avec les Noirs ça
partait très très bien ensuite il a
perdu avec les Blancs et il a perdu la
troisième avec les noirs et donc la
tendance
et quand même assez bonne pour Jordan
van forest si vous nous rejoignez
maintenant tâchez que allez azzafir
rouge à s'est imposé face à écart on a
qu'à moi il l'élimine dans le loser
bracket comme on dit et Jules Moussa
quant à lui éliminé shimanov donc de
Français qui sont toujours en vie dans
ce tournoi avec une défaite donc plus le
droit à l'erreur mais toujours là et on
les retrouvera dès demain tu les
retrouveras je sais pas avec qui tu
seras pas avec moi en tout cas demain je
serai avec alors demain c'était c'est ma
journée noire tu sais oh là là
des enfants et
mettre Kevin thérieux pour la journée
des enfants c'est quand même risqué mais
bon on va la programmation c'est c'est
Nathan qui fait ça il aura il devra
s'expliquer mais ouais bon après il faut
tu sais quand tu fais comme ça il y a
toujours un moment donné un prix à payer
donc donc voilà c'est demain en tout cas
et je crois que je suis avec le qu'une
seule journée et après je serai le reste
de l'événement jeudi et vendredi en
compagnie de Fabien ibizi que tout le
monde connaît bien sur la chaîne
donc voilà c'est vrai que là
Laurent et et la queue aujourd'hui enfin
hier et aujourd'hui du coup pour cet
événement et après je crois que tu nous
rejoins pour le nord-ouest
pas du tout ah non pas du tout ok
je serai au Top 16 ah oui c'est vrai oui
ça commence un petit peu après
donc je sais pas qui va te rejoindre
mais en tout cas pas moi c'est plus mais
je sais que je suis je sais pas
tu es là pour le Norwich c'est ça a
priori le film et après on avait dit que
peut-être éventuellement on regarderait
aussi ce qui se passe dans les phases
de la poule haute et basse du Top 16
donc la petite finale donc ça c'est
aussi intéressant on aura moyen
peut-être de te de te suivre
j'espère qu'on jouera la alors attention
c'est très chaud cette année c'est
peut-être l'année où il faut suivre
parce qu'il y a mon équipe je Vilaire
qui a gagné 4 fois
consécutive je crois c'est la 4e l'année
dernière mais on est quand même très
menacé hein faut avouer que Asnières a
une grosse équipe Chartres une grosse
équipe tout allons en Champagne grosse
équipe Clichy traditionnellement
traditionnellement une grosse équipe
donc il y a quand même énormément de
prétendants il peut se passer un peu
tout et donc c'est une année
particulièrement je trouve en tout cas
sympa à suivre les équipes
j'ouvre vraiment le jeu à fond les
équipes de de haut de tableaux et voilà
donc je pense qu'il y aura du
il y aura beaucoup de suspense dans la
pelote
ouais
un petit peu de souffler aussi un petit
peu avant avant l'entrée de canne échec
qui sera là
les grands favoris c'est vrai pardon les
grands favoris de l'année prochaine ils
seront à l'année prochaine donc là voilà
profitez bien cette année l'épouvantail
qu'à moi l'année prochaine ce sera pas
la même
ce sera pas la même l'année prochaine
alors il y a Valou 79 79 Valo qui m'a
dit tu as eu des bonus figure-toi que
oui en partie longue j'ai perdu une
partie et j'ai fait des nuls mais en
partie rapide j'ai un score positif j'ai
un score positif de deux victoires sans
défaite mais c'est à l'époque où Fabi tu
sais avec cette réputation et d'ailleurs
à juste titre d'être beaucoup moins fort
en partir rapide qu'en partie longue et
il a fait de gros progrès depuis je l'ai
pas rejoué depuis c'était je vous parle
de toi la dernière fois que j'ai joué
c'était en 2016 ça fait quand même
quelques années et voilà dans ces années
2013 2014
début 2010 jusqu'à 2015-2016 il était
quand même en difficulté dans les
rapides et c'était pas du tout un des
même s'il était numéro deux mondial à
cette époque là en classique mais en
rapide il faisait pas du tout peur et ça
se passait assez souvent assez mal pour
lui mais il a comme tous les
comme tous les grands joueurs il a su
voilà il a compris que les cadences
allaient accélérer
peut-être le déclic aussi ça a été le
mal champion du monde raté contre
12 parties nulles en particulier donc
clairement il était pas inférieur en
partie classique il y avait un match 6
partout c'était mérité et il était
balayé dans les rapides avec trois zéros
pour Magnus
limite main gauche tu vois enfin
vraiment on sent que assez facile l'anus
a archi dominé c'est des partages et
donc je crois qu'à partir de ce moment
là et aussi il faut faut le dire la
pandémie finalement le covid
a aidé ces joueurs là à faire des gros
progrès à jouer énormément à jouer
énormément online et donc à faire des
gros progrès rapides et maintenant c'est
tout simplement un des meilleurs joueurs
du monde en rapide donc
mon score en fait j'ai pas battu quand
il était petit mais j'ai battu quand il
était quand pour lui les échecs rapides
mais finalement c'était pas très
important il était très focus sur les
échecs classiques
et voilà maintenant ça serait ça sera un
peu plus compliqué on va on va regarder
ce score on va pas tout remiser on va
pas on va pas tout remettre sur le rouge
vous voyez ce que je veux dire faut pas
le faire ça j'ai un pote il est il est
2400 un peu ouais par là 2004 2350 et il
est 90 comme moi et il avait joué il
avait joué carvana en étant tout petit
allait être 10 ans quoi et bon le battre
à dis donc c'est déjà une belle perte
parce que quand tu as 10 ans et que tu
ben et tu vas quand même à 10 ans c'est
quand même pas mal mais battu et du coup
bah il est à 100 % quand le carbone
donc voilà c'est bien moi j'avais joué
contre je sais pas je t'avais déjà dit
mais là je vais contre un petit indien
dans pranave
et j'avais joué j'avais joué à d'autres
youtubeurs comme ça mais j'ai pas un
2006 qui doit avoir 7 ans
et mais après ouais j'avais joué aussi
un autre indien qu'on les appelait un
autre qui a 26 30 à peu près
au Festival des Jeux à Cannes il avait
14 ans
14 ans 2400 Hello
ça devient plus compliqué ensuite ouais
donc c'est pas en Alsace c'est à
Chartres dans cette belle ville de
Chartres on pourra le Top 16 c'est en
jours consécutifs
donc voilà l'organisation plus
professionnelle que
tu ou les autres divisions d'ailleurs
que vous jouez au club ou c'est plus le
week-end il y a beaucoup plus de joueurs
amateurs donc ça toute sa logique là
c'est vraiment le gros gros tournoi
c'est la Ligue 1
quand même la plupart des équipes ça
reste les équipes amateurs
malheureusement ont beaucoup de mal à se
maintenir bah nous on est on a fait un
passage on a l'impression de direct
ouais et encore vous aviez quand même
quelques jours bon alors ils étaient pas
enfin
qui était chaud
mais on en avait trois quand même enfin
quatre mais ils en ont trois qui
pouvaient jouer et
c'était et on a failli pas descendre
mais bon tu as rien en tout cas un peu
léger tu es un peu léger derrière quand
même on est libre de potes avant tout et
on n'est pas du tout pro donc
à l'époque on a parlé tout à l'heure
hein
jouer alors ils ont jamais gagné ils ont
jamais gagné c'est toujours c'était
Cannes la poisse c'est toujours un truc
qui malheureusement parce que au vu du
et alors qu'est-ce qui se passe dans ce
début écoute c'est très raisonnable
une catalane
Paypal
un peu mieux pour les blancs peut-être
mais sans plus hein
je suis même pas sûr
ouais et puis à 4
ouais c'est ça il s'active
un moment donné peut-être c'est ça
Damas 8 cavaliers F6 cavalier 4
peut-être ça paraît très raisonnable là
il y a une menace concrète c'est 5 c'est
4 qui jouent sur le clouage et attention
à cette dame après ensuite on peut
prendre en B3
je pense donc
ici pas bien
comment on explique le fait que le
classement des Tops joueurs a
pratiquement chuté plus qu'un jour au
dessus normalement ben ouais en fait je
pense qu'il y a un peu des périodes au
niveau de l'inflation et c'est que là je
crois que tu l'avais dit mais
historiquement on est on est très bas on
est très très bas parce que déjà vous
avez un il y a un site plus de 1700
hello je crois que c'est de Live 2700 et
il continue il y avait 37 joueurs à plus
du niveau de jeu donc ça baisse c'est
très dur c'est très dur de rester à 2007
c'est beaucoup plus dur maintenant que
que avant ça jamais été extrêmement
facile mais c'est plus dur parce que
voilà les joueurs à 2004-2005 joue mieux
tout simplement
voilà alors après c'est peut-être aussi
une période peut-être que dans le je dis
ça mais ça se trouve dans 6 mois il y a
15 joueurs de plus à 2007 après
vos amis il avait fait un 7 sur 7
il avait été en très grande forme
pendant un tournoi mais il est jamais
resté très longtemps quoi enfin il était
monté à 28 50 après il est quand même
resté un moment à 28-20 quand même il
avait fait un petit peu son nid
mais bon bah à un moment donné tu sais
que tu n'es pas tout le temps de ta
femme des fois tu as quand même des
tournois ou tu performe un peu moins
bien et tu peux pas rester au top mais
ça car voilà c'est quand même
considéré comme étant vraiment un des
meilleurs joueurs du monde bien sûr
derrière manuscarassen et après donc il
y a des joueurs bien sûr comme une
pommade comme Ding li Rennes comme
maintenant
à lire déjà qui qui sont là en train
d'essayer de de avec digne bien sûr je
voulais dire qui est champion du monde
actuel
donc voilà tous ces joueurs là qui
aurait un mot à dire pour vraiment
prendre cette seconde place mais ok la
deuxième place reste quand même c'est
très limité elle est pas gravée dans le
marbre
c'est pas clair vraiment de savoir bon
kidding a gagné le match mais bon c'est
c'est un match vraiment qui est pas
clair et puis bon quand même pas mal de
joueurs qui étaient pas invité à ce
matelas
mais avant le quart de scène il a quand
même
ouais mais bon
le deuxième donc c'est le deuxième place
à quand même une importance mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a il y a quand même 4-5
joueurs qui a qui va le vachement au
niveau de la deuxième place
et alors que bon quartier il y a quand
même un
je pense
[Musique]
et potentiellement de quoi
clairement et
même si là au Manchester il est pas en
forme bon ça reste toujours rapide
et il finit à plus d'un il finit alors
je peux te dire le classement on a dudun
avec 13 sur 18 donc il y aura 18 parties
de Blitz donc 18 points distribuer donc
c'est très ouvert à rognan 12 sur 18
wesh les sous et le français mvl à 11
sur 18 et manuscrit le scène addition 18
qui a gagné deux parties aujourd'hui
donc ça reste très très ouvert cette
histoire avec des Blitz où on sait des
séries de notamment mvl il nous a
habitué à il peut faire des très très
grosses journées Maxime il peut aussi en
faire des très mauvaises
mais clairement ça reste ça reste ouvert
on va voir c'est dommage que les
calendriers se clashent un petit peu on
aurait tellement aimé voir ces joueurs
là dans ce champion de chasse tour
mais c'est comme ça bon je pense que les
sur les prochaines années il y a quand
même des chances raisonnables que tout
le monde se mette d'accord pour remarque
aussi c'est ce qu'a dit Jules ça permet
de voir d'autres joueurs c'est comme ça
pas de voir d'autres joueurs voilà de
découvrir et puis même ça permet aussi
[Musique]
de faire participer tu vois prendre
Jules il est il est là il est hyper
content d'être là et d'ailleurs bah lui
il a dit qu'il espérait battu maintenant
pour jouer encore un fort derrière enfin
il veut jouer contre le carwana il veut
jouer comme ça quoi il veut s'améliorer
et c'est vrai que normalement votre
tournoi lambda ben il est pas invité
quoi pour un pour un événement aussi
fort donc il est très content d'avoir sa
place ici en tout cas être participé de
les multiples donc vraiment c'était cool
ça donne la place à de nouveaux joueurs
qui peuvent essayer de faire un peu
leurs preuves contre des joueurs qui
sont habitués maintenant
dans ce genre de circuit quoi donc c'est
vraiment cool et on espère te voir te
qualifier toi aussi un jour je crois que
tu étais très très
dommage j'ai joué ce match j'étais des
en plus bref j'ai pas joué une rampe pas
été à Paris normande donc bon au moins
parce qu'il y a plusieurs divisions
c'est vrai qu'on touche quoi la division
1 mais il y a des visions 2 et divisions
3 donc c'est quand même ça laisse ça
laisse de la place pour se qualifier
sur les fin de journée ça joue moins
bien
tout devient plus aléatoire
et tout devient enfin en tout cas c'est
l'impression que j'ai eu mais tout
devient
très possible ou pas on verra
salut
et Marc échec qui nous rejoint alors
on est un tout petit peu mieux avec les
Blancs peut-être mais même pas je sais
pas ça tranquille est-ce que tu as
regardé un peu ce qui s'est passé à côté
ou pas où tu veux que j'aille voir
rapidement
la partie de l'école j'ai regardé il est
très bien on va aller voir ouais
peut-être il est très bien cool
[Musique]
le score c'est demain pour pour attends
je l'ai pas changé là par contre je vais
cliquer dessus mais j'ai pas donc il y a
deux un pour vendre forest qui a les
Noirs donc en cas de non défaite et ben
avec le match sur le chant par contre si
collars gagne cette partie avec les
Blancs et ben il forcerait un arnaque et
donc
tout à fait et il a un peu en plus qui a
l'air assez nul quoi que il y a un peu
de jeu quand même
mais bon il joue de manière très logique
Colars
je sais pas si tu as vu je sais pas si
c'est un peu la fatigue mais en tout cas
ça joue plus vite j'ai l'impression
maintenant après c'est les matchs c'est
compliqué
regardez le même niveau de concentration
à moins que c'est que ça soit un choix
complètement conscient des joueurs de
d'accélérer la cadence
mutuellement ouais aussi aussi de passer
ses distances et ouais tu as raison de
passer distance au temps
on a vu on a vu ce cas de figure
avec tendance à empêcher un peu plus que
que vous reste l'impression donc
on fait quoi on reste sur on regarde nos
champions
où on regarde moi j'irais plutôt voir à
besanteur mais après tu vois vas-y vas-y
surtout qu'il a fait une gaffe je crois
Fabiano Carana qui prend des 7
étourcisses qui pour arriver puis on
prend les quatre est un coup perdu
il se passe quoi
il se passe quoi et B4 pion prend V4
qu'est-ce qui se passe
8 cavalue 5 B4 il y a eu B C prend B4 et
là c'est une gaffe et pourquoi qui prend
des scènes à me prendre des 7 tours
c'est ça je vous parlais de la fatigue
regardez moi cette fatigue non ça marche
pas c'est pas ça
c'est quoi le coup là
tu peux pas trop l'empêcher non je sais
pas
alors on tente des trucs
mais attention il y a un très très bel
avantage pour les blancs de toute façon
c'est pas trop content généralement avec
les noirs de devoir faire c'est prendre
des cartes c'est une belle concession
ok donc ton conseil 6 et ben c'est le
plan qui enfin qui va être récupéré par
des Blancs et une belle pression sur les
sur les pions des cinq blessés tu as
peur de fou pour les blancs la colonne C
écoute j'aime beaucoup la production de
la maison
je le vois bien gagner ce match
gagné cette partie là d'ailleurs et ne
pas aller au départ
d'accord ouais j'aime beaucoup la
position blanche surtout qu'on peut
récupérer notre dû
un peu quand on veut en P4 c'est pas
vraiment une angoisse bon là il reprend
le 2 c'est pas tout à fait quand on veut
c'est pas comment on joue parce que je
peux retrouver
non mais en partie lente c'est tous les
jours mais là bon ça fait 4h30 qui sont
en train de jouer enfin pour 4h30 mais
au moins trois bonnes heures
c'est du rapide bon
tu es un peu moins alerte quoi mais
sinon alors niveau cette technique là
standard je pense
j'adore comment il joue ce jeune homme
j'adore
3 minutes d'avance pour Abdou ça torov
qui met une pression dingue sur
encore une fois regarde la caméra il est
il est tellement sérieux il est
tellement tellement focus j'ai tellement
motivé par le dernier degré notre ami
Abdou Sator a fait salut au boulot merci
c'est très gentil
vraiment moi je suis impressionné par ça
par ce joueur enfin j'ai toujours dit et
rien que la latitude elle est je trouve
c'est tellement exemplaire
voilà après ça garantit pas en vrai
Magnus qui est un peu plus dans le style
un peu plus désinvoltes enfin beaucoup
plus désole
c'est pas forcément une garantie de
succès ou de non succès mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai qu'il fait penser à Garica il
a quelque chose de très casse pas
revient dans son dans son attitude et
faut dire que
Gary a une carrière tout à fait honnête
comme résultat
à la fin tu auras le fou qui va manger
là en C8 le fou H3 si tu prends des six
je prends là et
dans un combattant quand même ici
comment tu vas défaire tout ça
et tu en prends deux tu l'as dit tu
perds la pièce nette cavalier qui va
être perdu
alors il a il a joué il a joué et il a
battu il a battu l'immense talent un
Nakamura
sur deux parties nul la première guerre
la deuxième une super partie la deuxième
c'était génial et il rejoue et on joue
demain 17h demain contre le perdant de
ce matelas donc peut-être non pardon oui
attends oui c'est ça il va jouer contre
imagine très certainement
et ben il jouera contre même carvana
qui jouera en finale contre le gagnant
de l'autre match donc
possiblement aussi encore une fois reste
[Musique]
le 3 en solidifie tout ça pas d'histoire
on va faire tomber un on va encaisser ce
pion en V4 ou tours c'est un tour C8
aussi et dans les dans les plans enfin
en gros on va activer cette tour pour
donner le coup de massue mais ça m'a
l'air tellement facile
Thor c'est un roi j'ai 7 tours C8
cavaliers je sais même pas où tu vas
arriver
comme ça aussi
sur pour C8
quand même tu as envie de le faire mais
c'est un concret comment tu continues
essaie d'aller manger le pion des cinq
[Musique]
tours quand même assez simple enfin tu
as envie de passer par là
comment je passe
pas si évident non non il a trouvé la
bonne défense en tout cas
juste pour embêter alors pas instant
collarer
contre dame fou tu peux aller voir
rapidement ouais pour juste pour montrer
la position est-ce qu'on va avoir un
Armageddon aujourd'hui ça dépend très
certainement beaucoup beaucoup de cette
partie il faut que les Blancs
c'est pas c'est pas fait mais il y a des
chances si ça gagne armage si
les Noirs tiennent
une retienne et ben ce sera
vampires en finale contre probablement
probablement App Store et color
Carpentras
et bon objectivement je sais pas ce que
tu en penses moi au pif comme ça je
dirais que ça objectivement c'est nul
mais ok ça va pas être facile pas
alors on va voir si nous montre ça
on l'a tellement
vanter c'est mérite dans la dans la
partie technique
je suppose
il a redonné pour simplifier peut-être
deux points d'exclamation
waouh ah ouais non mais c'est
alors je crois qu'on ouais prends des
cinq tours à 5 jouets ok fou c'est 4
précis comme
décision quoi bien la position il sait
que ça va tomber dans une qualité plus
je veux tu veux la garder pour en plus
tu pouvais ramener les deux tours sur la
8e
tout le monde aurait fait ça c'est hyper
naturel mais bon toujours un petit peu
de contre-jour quoi et lui il a rendu le
matériel pour gagner deux pions en fait
au final c'est pareil ce qu'il a fait
parce qu'il a fait un échange de tour
qui vaut 5 points contre un fou qui en
vaut 3 pour gagner après deux pions donc
au final il remplit tellement la tâche
c'est ça là il va avoir une finale en
fait avec deux pions plus et depuis en
plus matériellement ça équivaut à une
qualité de plus donc ouais non c'est
c'est le masterclass encore une fois
d'ailleurs on sent un peu mieux compte
de hier Jules avait quand même très très
forte affaire vraiment c'était
pas je crois que c'était le pire
apparemment de ce qu'on voit depuis le
début c'était le pire à Paris parce que
Nakamura est pas du tout à son niveau
habituel
à quand même un peu s'énerver mais là
tout ça t'auras ses pointu c'est précis
c'est bien préparé en fait le meilleur
pour l'instant merde c'est vraiment le
joueur qui est
qui est comment dire
hyper en forme quoi et
c'est un joueur qui
t'a du mal vraiment à
surprendre et à je sais pas comment dire
il est il est tout en forme quoi
il est impressionnant alors où est-ce
qu'il va mettre
favori du tournoi là faut être fin ou
faut deux ça je sais jamais
pour le bas
ket
[Musique]
attention il y a des petits pièges E4
j'ai envie de pousser mes pions
évidemment les pions passés sont faits
pour être pousser je demandais ce qui se
passait sur tour à 4 ouais c'est ça
exactement
[Musique]
pas si évident
tours
[Musique]
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe sur ton C5
B4
c'est la partie
[Musique]
comme ça ah ouais
et tu vas réussir à stabiliser
[Musique]
en C4 et oui domine complètement le
cavalier regardez ce cavalier
complètement dominé par ce fou ces
quatre qui va venir oh c'est pas tant
c'est épatant ce qui nous fait autour se
cache mais regardez justement ça fait
intéressant
ou pas
franchement il est franchement présent
et comme je le disais on va généralement
pas rater des parties gagnantes quoi
quand il est vraiment gagnant
[Musique]
gagnant techniquement il faut pas trop
de choses
alors que en face ça se défend ça se
défend ça se défend et plein de fois il
y a des ratés même à haut niveau mais
lui tu le vois pas trop trop
généralement il est gagnant il va gagner
quoi je parle vraiment de la technique
comme ça là par exemple
ça va être abandon je pense avoir
un petit tour
[Musique]
ouais je vois pas non non il va pas la
perdre celle-là
[Musique]
je sais ce qu'il va faire E4 à la place
de ça dans ton B2 là oui
je veux
OK
c'est évident que les noirs sont
perdants là
est-ce qu'on fait tout B7 tours C7 OK
quoi
[Musique]
comment tu tiens ça
c'est pas encore pour
Fabi essaie de trouver une solution qui
n'existe pas donc ça sera posé le plus
de problèmes le l'enjeu là donc pour ces
trois fous E4 c'était le coup qu'on
voulait faire mais il y a plus qu'à
passer
et surtout C4
[Musique]
qui a été joué est-ce qu'il va jouer au
4 à 12 septembre alors on en est où là
pour cette 3
e
c'est vrai que
où vas-tu
[Musique]
complètement il en veut plus elle
est là et ça va être abandon parce que
sur
F7 Tourcoing R6 et
abandon
donc victoire de qui sera
qui sera en finale un contrôle contre on
sait pas encore
contre regarde le pion qui avançait
l'option de colère
[Musique]
et c'était nul quelques coups avant mais
là il a laissé trois avancer le roi
apparemment c'est complètement perdant
maintenant
j'ai perdu mais mes caméras avec les
joueurs qui qui sont sortis de qui sont
déconnectés et collars qui jouent ça
carta fond il a bien raison il envoie
son roi
et ouais il va chercher la Maguet dans
effectivement
changer mes caméras du coup et là en
fait il va il va se cacher en C8
ça va être c'est juste complètement
terminé
c'est juste complètement terminé
ouais ouais il va y avoir des 7 on va
couvrir les chèques comme ça
il va gagner il va faire le miracle là
peut-être qui redonne qui a un ouais qui
a du raté quelque chose avant c'est
jamais évident ce final de dame parce
qu'on peut croire qu'on a perpète mais
en fait on l'a pas
c'est certainement ce que tu as dû
penser yorden
et là regardez dame 8 sur une gaffe à
cause de dame D8 et là il va jouer Road
B8 ok reviens et dame B7 et maintenant
il y a plus d'échec mais les dames 5
encore oh c'est pas fini quand même
c'est pas si facile pour les blancs
alors évidemment la jauge elle met que
c'est gagnant pour les blancs mais c'est
jamais si simple ces histoires faut
toujours se méfier
et il a quand même assez peu de temps
enfin une minute bon il y a les 10
secondes non c'est dit c'est 3 secondes
d'incrément donc oui non c'est pas
complètement fait cet Armageddon
[Musique]
c'est pas un match c'est mérité
où j'ai 5 MD8 c'est bien joué j'ai 5 km
des 8 on fait roi de 5 ans donc
attention
il faut évidemment se créer des pions
passés c'est la base en finale de dames
et ça pourrait peut-être suffire
sont fatigués
[Musique]
ok il va ici
il veut se garder le Dame des cinq
probablement on a déjà eu cette position
et là il y a même pas besoin de réclamer
le c'est automatique
sur roi D8 on fait puis on prend H4 et
ça y est on a notre contre le jeu
3 x 7 peut-être j'ai trois mesdames j'ai
trois il y aura perpète ensuite et c'est
nul maintenant c'est nul mais attends
bon
et H2 qui arrive elle voit
même la perdre
pourquoi le match
il est revenu du Diable Vauvert
d'un B7 H2 H2 maintenant c'est terminé
parce qu'on fait on fait un milliard
d'échecs on peut plus couvrir ouais
c'est là que tu ADM G28
on aura perpète et franchement super
défense de vente forest qui a réussi à
G5 H4 c'était vraiment
et c'est nul c'est nul ouh là là c'est
rageant pour le joueur allemand
essayer hein mais bon dame là dame là
mais bon
tu prends tu fais dame tu en plus donc
là tu vas la gagner et tu continues à
parler d'échecs ça va répéter et c'est
nul tu mets le roi ici et ben je le fais
chèque là encore une fois tu peux pas
échanger
tu perds défense pratique
qui se qualifie du coup pour jouer alors
si j'ai pas de bêtises on va on va tout
vous redire maintenant
parce que j'ai le bracket qui est qui
est ici donc on a Caravana qui va jouer
contre fearuja donc demain on a Collard
ce qui va jouer contre Jules demain
aussi vente forest ce qui va jouer les
demi-finales contre app du Rohff demain
aussi donc on a encore trois petits
matchs très très sympathiques et
ensuite finale enfin là déjà demain
c'est une première petite finale avant
de Forest à 2h qui qualifiant pour la
vraie grande finale
et le perlant du match de adventure of
demain jouera contre je pense je vois la
finale
c'est un peu compliqué mais en gros
vous avez vous avez des joueurs qui ont
perdu vous avez karwana firouza colors
Moussa
petit père prend éliminé et les deux
gagnants
des 2 mm ça remonteront pour une
demi-finale de la poule des perdants le
gagnant de cette demi-finale de la
groupe est perdant donc des quatre un
carbonates
il en reste un seul
le seul qui sortira vainqueur celle là
je vois contre le perdant de Van forest
of the torov pour jouer une grande
finale contre le gagnant de vente forest
un peu c'est un peu compliqué mais
finalement on s'y fait donc donc voilà
une belle journée en tout cas
aujourd'hui avec pas mal de très belles
parties à 12 ans on est complètement
charmé par ce talent de ce jeune homme
il est incroyable il est incroyable d'où
cette Europe maintenant je crois qu'il
est il est grand favori de ce tournoi ça
me paraît évident on a vu une belle
réaction des français plutôt avec airesa
qu'il est emporté face à icaruna Camorra
qui l'a éliminé même et Jules Moussa qui
reviendra comme tu l'as dit dans le dans
le contre Collard on verra il a toutes
ses chances en tout cas il a battu
aujourd'hui il a éliminé lui aussi
shimanov
donc bah écoute ça reste très très beau
à voir tu vas commenter ça demain avec
Kevin thérieux avec Kevin thérieux
exactement et
donc demain pareil à 17h comme
aujourd'hui donc bien sûr on vous attend
nombreux donc Laurent ne sera pas là
demain il m'abandonne je serai avec
Kevin thérieux mais l'événement continue
et puis j'espère que vous serez demain
en tout cas très nombreux pour la suite
de l'événement alors avant de partir on
va partir avec un petit réel vous savez
qu'on aime bien faire les Red sur la
chaîne et merci à tous et je vous dis à
moi je recommanderais plus ça ni le nom
richesse mais je vous dis à bientôt pour
de nouvelles aventures sur le jeu sur le
champion de chasseur très